Hello, hello everybody!
I just realized I didn't open my chat, give me a- I was like, something looks a little different.
I was like, oh wait, I don't even have chat open.
Oh my god, I still like this.
Oh, thank you for the 10 gifted shows, thank you, thank you!
I'm just booting up my chat right now.
I...
I don't know why I'm like this, guys.
Why am I like this?
Alright, there we go.
Don't worry, you guys are alive now.
I got you guys.
Alright, today is a big Overwatch 2 update!
Juno!
I can finally try out Juno for the first time!
We were not able to play Juno before because I didn't realize Juno was there.
Juno was like limit- Juno playtest ended so early.
Because usually, usually, you know, I didn't realize it was like a sneak peek thing.
So her abilities are very interesting.
So she has this thing which makes you shoot faster and stuff.
So you can shoot faster when you're in it and stuff.
And then we have the fly.
So we can float and stuff like Echo.
And then we have this.
Which is pretty interesting.
It locks onto enemies as well.
You can walk around too with that.
But oops, I sort of didn't use that correctly.
It's timed.
It's not in rank so like we can't test this out in rank.
But basically what this does is that it locks into people and then it locks into enemies.
Fuck, I cancelled it again.
You have to right- left click afterwards and I'm so not used to that.
Sorry, I cancelled it again.
Okay, now!
And then you see that.
So it damages people and it can heal at the same time.
The cooldowns are not that bad.
But I feel like they're just gonna nerf that when she's in rank usually.
And then her ult.
Her ult, she does everything fast.
Her ult is basically her abilities but like bigger and lasting longer I assume.
But it just makes her fast as well.
So yeah, she's pretty interesting.
Her damage is not that...
It's not great.
Her heal output seems fine.
Her heal output seems to be similar to Ana with like one shot.
But instead it's multiple shots.
But DPS healers are always great.
It's great to have DPS healers.
Actually, yeah, it's always great.
DPS healers are always considered like pretty meta.
So like...
I don't know.
She could be good.
I can't tell yet.
I can't tell.
It's been a while since I follow like Overwatch meta.
But she seems pretty decent.
She seems very fun to play.
And like that's what Overwatch needs.
Like something fun to play.
Because like...
There hasn't been like lots of fun characters lately.
So...
They also...
They just need fun characters.
Yeah, she can't crit.
So it's mostly like...
Mostly if I had to pick between Ilari or Juno.
I feel like if I'm here to do damage, I'd pick...
I'd pick Ilari over Juno.
But then Juno has like the Lucio speed boost thing.
Which is this.
So you can't control where it goes.
So assume like when you're facing...
What you're facing is where it's gonna go.
So it's just a speed boost.
The GR66, they're thinking about it.
They're not actually implementing it yet.
It's more so...
I feel like they say that just to gauge audience's reactions.
Just see what people would think.
It's not a speed boost.
Oh, it's a damage amp?
Oh, okay.
Alright.
It feels...
I feel faster.
Maybe it's because like her gun is so fast.
So, okay.
It's basically...
A damage boost.
Oh, okay.
That's interesting.
It's a very offensive ult.
And then I heard there's two new maps.
There's like...
They brought...
They basically brought back Hanamura and Anubis.
But like not 2CP.
Which fucking sucks.
Because I'm like...
I actually like 2CP.
The clash game mode sounds terrible.
I don't know.
Maybe it's not bad.
I'll try...
I'll look it out.
I'll check it out.
Okay.
Let's see.
Custom games.
Is it out now?
Clash is out, right?
Yeah.
It's like 5CP.
I'm Chuno.
For Juno.
Alright.
Let's see if it is out.
Yeah.
It is.
Clash is out.
God damn.
Okay.
Alright.
So, Clash.
I don't really understand what Clash is.
To be fair.
I read it.
And it like...
It was...
It looked so confusing.
I'm...
I'm gonna straight up say it.
Like, I was so confused.
I was like...
I was reading it.
The fuck does that mean?
I...
I was like...
There's so many points.
And then one of my friends was trying to explain Clash to me.
I'm like...
I still don't understand.
Okay.
So...
Hanaka is basically Hanamura.
So, we will explore...
We will explore...
I mean...
It literally is Hanamura.
It literally looks like Hanamura.
So, we will explore...
Yeah.
Okay.
Toggle war with maps.
That sounds...
Oh, God.
I fucking hate...
I fucking hate push.
This sounds like push.
All right.
Oh.
Oh, there's three openings?
Oh, my God.
They can count to three.
Okay.
So...
What?
Okay.
So, that's one of the points, I assume.
Oh, my God.
Oh, this is...
Oh, I'm sorry.
But...
Oh.
Oh, my God.
And apparently, if you capture the last...
If you can capture the last point, you automatically win.
So...
So if you capture the last point...
Where am I?
Where's the last point?
I won't know.
So if you capture point E, you automatically win.
Or if they capture point A...
Then they automatically win.
So, but that's like so... you either have to capture all the points or A or E.
And I guess like... but I wonder if there's... there has to be a time limit.
There's no way.
Yeah, there's too much move... yeah, that's why when I read it, I was like, oh, that's moving...
That's just so much for rank, you know?
It's a lot.
It's definitely gonna be like super chaotic and stuff.
All points are first to five.
Oh god, that's... that's a long game.
That sounds... that sounds like... that sounds like a very long game.
It sounds like a very stressful game.
Because you have to defend everything!
You have to defend so many places.
Alright, we're gonna see how that's like.
Oh my god, I'm... I'm getting too old for this.
I'm just like, oh my god, that's too many points to figure out.
Yeah...
Okay...
As an Overwatch veteran, my mind is already, like, overwhelmed.
I'm now... it's like, hey, let's get rid of two CP.
Let's get rid of two CP and add five CP.
That's what people want.
Whoa!
Alright.
I mean...
There's really not much to show for Hanamura.
Um, because it's like...
It's literally Hanamura plus the...
This literally looks like...
Oh hey, Dog Cafe.
This literally looks like Hanamura plus the...
Uh...
Plus the...
What was it called?
What's the other map?
For...
Um...
Deathmatch?
This looks like Deathmatch...
The Deathmap match plus Hanamura at the same time.
Um...
So...
Yeah, like, so...
I don't...
I don't feel like...
Whoa!
Because it literally looks like that.
It doesn't look much different.
Um...
It has, like, all the...
Like, this is from Hanamura.
The lore building for Hanzo, Genji, and Kiriko.
And then this is also Hanamura.
I remember this.
They're just missing, like, the thing there.
And this is the Team Deathmatch here.
This is Team Deathmatch.
This is Han...
Oh, no.
This is...
Yeah, this is Team Deathmatch.
Yeah, this is literally, like, a mixture between the Team Deathmatch map and then Hanamura.
So I'm like, oh, it just looks like that.
I'm curious about Anubis.
I think Anubis might be interesting.
The new Anubis.
Let me look at that real quick.
All right.
All right, here we go.
What's funny?
I love...
Like, not love, but, like, the current, like...
The current, like, Twitter drama beef about Anubis is the fact that they chose Reaper to represent Anubis.
And people were like, why the fuck not Ramatra?
The people were really mad.
There was...
There wasn't...
There was not only that, but there was the Overwatch skins drama.
Because they announced another Mercy skin and another Kiriko skin.
And everybody...
Like, and apparently Venture still hasn't...
Still doesn't have, like, a skin yet.
Or apparently, like, a new skin yet.
And then my...
One of my favorite...
One of my fav...
Like, so everybody is, like, yelling at Kiriko and Mercy mains right now.
Because everybody was like, another skin for Mercy and Kiriko?
And...
And then I...
There was this meme that's being posted of, like, fucking...
Of, like...
Like, basically, Mercy and Venture players being overfed as hell.
While...
While, like, all the other characters are dehydrated.
You know, exactly.
They're, like...
They're, like, when...
My favorite...
Someone was like, you know when Blizzard needs to pay the bills.
When they release another Mercy and Kiriko skin.
But, like, the MVP...
I mean...
I mean true.
They are the ones that buy skins.
There's no...
Guys, it's...
There's not enough Venture players to justify making another skin for them, guys.
Like, there's not enough Venture players.
We all know...
DPS players don't really buy...
Like, okay.
Some DPS players do buy skins.
But, if you compare the Mercy skin players...
The Mercy players versus...
There's more people buying Mercy skins than there are people buying the entirety of DPS skins.
I'll say it.
I ain't afraid to say it.
And we all know it's true.
And when you combine all the people that buy Mercy skins versus DPS, the whole entire DPS category, there will still be more people buying Mercy skins than there are DPS skins.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter if the skin is so fucking cool.
They know their market.
The thing is, Mercy players, they want all the Mercy skins.
Like, no joke, even back in my prime.
Like, even back in my prime in Overwatch, like, I would see so many people bragging about, like, the completion-ness of Mercy.
That's why some people were willing, before the pink Mercy skins, before the crash of the pink Mercy skin stock market.
Oh, that's Anubis.
Before the crash of the pink Mercy skin Anubis, those skins sold for, like, more than a thousand dollars.
Because, like, accounts that had pink Mercy skin.
Because people were like, people were like, we have to complete the collection.
Like, we have to complete the Mercy collection.
And I do not see any DPS players doing that.
You guys gotta show your devotion.
If you want that skin.
Alright.
Not gonna lie...
I'm not...
It's just Anubis.
Like, there's the Anubis door.
And then there's...
Is that Horus?
I assume?
I can't remember my Egyptian gods right now.
That's also Anubis.
I'm gonna get so many people mad if I say that.
And then there's...
And then there's Anubis.
And then...
Bring back...
No, absolutely not.
I don't...
Paris?
Paris is the most terrible map.
Paris, no.
Keep Paris locked up.
No amount of improvement can ever fix Paris.
I had people legitimately quit games.
Like, leave ranked games.
Because of how bad.
How dodgy.
The Paris map was.
In like...
Not like in low elo.
In fucking grandmaster games, chat.
Like, Lunar Calling was bad.
But at least it was not Paris bad.
Like, I actually...
Legitimately had people in grandmaster...
Like, grandmaster players...
Willingly leave games.
So they don't have to play this.
They don't have to play Paris.
It's actually crazy how bad that map is.
Like...
That...
They're like...
Elo...
Elo is not worth...
Like, to them, they're like...
Elo is...
Paris is to the point where Elo is not worth it for their sanity.
Like...
What makes the Paris map bad?
It's just very poorly designed.
Um...
Attacking it is hell.
Because they have like 200 fucking high ground.
So it's very hard to...
Contest the high ground.
Because like...
Uh...
They have like...
This platform thing.
And then...
Obviously...
To get to high ground...
You have to...
Walk past people.
It's similar to Lunar Colony.
Lunar Colony people have like...
So many high ground.
So like...
Imagine like...
The...
In order to like...
Get past...
To the point...
You have to contest a...
Full high ground players here.
And then...
The only way to get past high ground...
Is you have to walk...
To here.
Look at this!
Look at them.
And then turn right.
And then the high ground players...
Can all look at you...
While you try...
And then...
And then walk up the stairs.
Like...
Literally.
Or walk up here.
Like...
It was...
It was that bad.
So...
So imagine...
Okay.
This is literally how Paris looks like.
So the corridors were a lot smaller.
It was a lot smaller.
And you were just like...
You have to walk.
You see all of them here.
They're all like...
Being like...
What the fuck are you doing?
And then you have to...
See them.
And then walk here.
In a corridor.
So...
I don't know.
I don't know if you can actually select Paris.
I'll be funny if you can.
Wait.
Is Paris...
Can you like actually...
Bring back Paris?
In custom settings?
Let's try it out.
All right.
Let's see.
Is there still...
Is there still 2CP?
No.
They literally got rid of it.
Wait.
Unless...
Is it?
Is it this?
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
I'll show you guys.
No.
That is...
Oh my god.
That's control.
I don't know.
I forgot the names of everything.
It's been so long.
I...
It's a sub.
I was like...
I saw like 2CP.
And I was like...
C.
Control.
I didn't know why.
I was like...
C.
Control.
All right.
Let's see.
I'll show you...
I'll show you why this is one of the most hated maps of all of Overwatch.
All right.
Here we go.
And then Lunar Colony faces a similar issue, but not as bad as...
Not as bad as...
As Paris.
So...
All right.
So as defender...
As the defender...
Oh my god.
I forgot this is...
They turned this into a team deathmatch map because they're like, we already made Paris.
Wait.
What do we do with this?
All right.
You see that?
For those who've never played Paris...
You said, Paris.
All right, here it is.
You thought I was...
Here it is.
Literally, I look at you.
Literally.
You can't do anything...
You have to walk here.
You're attacking...
You walk up....
You die.
And you know what was meta...
You have to walk here.
You know what was meta?
Oh my god!
Fucking Junkrat!
They just... they're like, oh, I didn't get a shield!
Then we get one fucker playing Junkrat!
And then they just spam this corridor!
And then they just...
They just...
Spam this corridor!
Over and over and over and over!
And Torb Junkrat right here!
They just spam this...
Pew pew pew pew pew!
And then you were like, oh no!
What do I do?
Um...
So this was fucking terrible to play!
Because you have like one second to be like...
But then obviously they're spamming!
Or you, you know, you be a little bossy and go here and storm...
You storm the high ground.
Here.
Nobody would ever go left!
Cause like, if you go left...
Like, look at how much high ground they have here to kill you!
Um, and yeah!
That's why...
That's why nobody fucking...
Nobody fucking liked Paris!
It was so fucking bad to play!
Uh...
They all had every high ground possible!
Uh, so yeah!
That's why they...
I'm pretty sure Paris is one of the main reasons why they like, got...
I'm 100% certain Paris is like the main reason why 2CP does not exist anymore.
Paris was that bad.
And then, um...
People were like, okay...
People really hated Lunar Colony as well, but...
For those who never had Lunar Colony...
It got so bad, they literally took Paris out of rotation.
Like...
The fact that like...
The Paris map got taken out of rotation and then later on...
2CP was gone forever.
I love Lunar Colony.
It's so fucking terrible to play attack on.
Though, it's against high elo players.
So, it's similar, but like, you know, they all have the high ground here.
So all they do is just go... they just go pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew and then when, you know, you're defending...
It's a little bit easier because you can come from here or here and then you just go like that and then you're free.
I guess.
Because their high ground is also like...
Their high ground is higher.
It's higher.
So like, less chance to really be able to kill you because they have to... they have more distance to shoot you.
And then I guess, but in high elo it's still fucking hell because they can... they have aim.
Like, they...
Yeah, but they have more distance.
So, it's harder for higher elo.
It's so fucking hell in higher elo because they can still aim.
It's not like they can't fucking aim for shit.
But like, it is easier to storm the high ground versus Paris because, like, they're further away from you.
Like, they have to be here or usually they're like here.
But yeah, that was the life of 2CP.
That was... those were the only shit maps in 2CP.
The other maps were fine.
I was fine with the other maps.
It might take like 20 years to finish a game, but like I was fine.
I had like no issues with it.
Alright, let's try out Juno.
Oh wait, I want to do Clash.
Okay, wait.
Clash should be in our arcade, right?
Yeah, there it is.
Alright, let's try out Clash and Juno.
Yeah.
I've had I've had 2CP games that went max.
One time.
One time I actually legitimately played the maxed out, the maxed out 2CP limit on Volskaya.
It was literally on Volskaya where you can max it out.
Volskaya had such a snowball um like map design that is the easiest to make it all the way to the end.
Yes, right.
You don't get Juno.
I get Juno.
All the OG maps were really cool.
I enjoyed all of them.
I loved Anubis, Volskaya, Hanamura, King's Row, Route 66.
Route 66 I've started not enjoying it as much because it's like I don't know.
It's just as a support player, Route 66 is not that fun for me.
It's very stressful.
I feel like out of all the maps for support for the OG maps Route 66 is like one of the most stressful maps to play as a support player.
Alright.
I enjoyed Hanamura.
Yeah.
I actually enjoyed it.
Alright.
How the fuck do you play this map?
What the fuck?
Alright.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Let's figure this out.
Alright.
Okay.
How do I do that?
Alright.
Okay.
It's not that bad.
I mean it's pretty...
It's pretty...
You can lead to heal botting.
Not gonna lie.
Oh!
It's literally right there.
It's right next to me.
I don't know how you feel.
I mean this is literally like the first couple of games.
Oh!
Poop!
Alright.
What the fuck was he doing?
Go away!
I got you!
That's fucking right!
I can... Oh shit!
Give me a sec.
Lara, you gotta help him.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Don't worry.
Please kill Zarya!
I think he's shooting him!
Somebody kill him!
Alright.
We captured another point.
Nice.
That was easy.
Alright.
We're good.
I almost have ult.
Alright.
I wanna use my ult for the next capture.
I need to like be aware of the...
Okay.
Oh no!
There was no way to save you!
How the fuck was I supposed to save you?
Oh god.
The point is gonna open.
Wait.
Where's the point?
Oh it's over there!
Oh god.
No!
Alright.
Oh it's fine.
That's fine.
Oh god.
Orbit time!
Oh.
Nice.
Alright.
We're good.
Easy!
Alright.
This is such a fast-paced game.
Holy shit.
Alright.
That's another point.
This is super fast-paced.
I don't know if I like that.
We'll see.
Let me go.
Wait.
The point is this...
Oh wait.
No.
We haven't capped it!
I'm trying my best!
Please!
My heal output is not as much as I thought it was!
Okay.
Oh he's one!
He's one!
That's fucking right.
You can't fucking kill me.
I'm gonna fucking fly to you.
Oh shit!
I'm sorry!
I didn't realize...
I forgot...
Like...
That point is literally in their spawn.
Like how...
The point is literally in their spawn.
How is that fair?
How is that fucking fair?
It's literally in their spawn!
Alright.
We need to...
Okay.
Oh I need to get away from that.
Oh god.
How do I... No.
No I can't get to you!
You're behind the wall!
I'm trying my best!
No!
It's okay.
I can fly away.
Alright.
That's the neat part.
No.
Don't worry I got you.
That's fine.
I don't think I could do that in rank though.
These people actually have aim in rank.
I know like there's no SPMM in arcades.
I get front line as support.
Alright.
Nice we got another.
Yeah no arcade I can tell they don't have aim.
So I'm not like...
I'm not like intimidated.
I'm not very intimidated with this team.
Alright.
It unlocks at 14 seconds.
I'm gonna wait.
Did I kill anybody?
Oh no.
It's okay I fly away.
Fly away.
Oh.
I guess not.
I should have used my ult.
How was I supposed to know that was gonna happen?
Oh.
Goodbye.
Sorry.
I'm sorry I leave you.
Sorry I'm sorry.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Holy shit!
Get away from me!
Fucking idiots.
You're still here?
What?
Is he still here?
How did I get to him?
He's hungry.
Oh my god.
How the fuck is he still there?
Stupid ass soldier.
Okay.
Shit.
I'm trying to like figure out some of these.
These.
Alright.
Stupid soldier.
It's fine.
I'm not scared.
Oh shit.
Alright.
There you go.
Oh!
They got him?
No way!
They pushed him away!
Goodbye.
Stop!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
It's just we're getting staggered.
This hard punishes staggers so much.
It sucks.
Cause like it punishes staggering.
To a big degree.
Cause the moment you respawn the point's open.
So it's not very great.
There we go.
Oh no!
My orbit!
It
staggers!
Guys, I think we might lose.
Oh my god.
Why do I always get carbon?
I always get carbon.
Every time.
Oh no.
Yeah, this is like a hard stagger punishment.
I don't like that.
Oh no.
We lost, guys.
I got the...
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh god, please.
Let's go in.
What do you want me to do?
I was flying!
No!
That was so cocky!
I was like, it's so easy.
Oh my god.
Why was I so cocky?
Every time!
Every fucking time!
Carbon.
It's not fair!
Okay, I hate clash.
Now I'm def...
Now I'm a real hater.
It's cause the staggers fucking suck.
Cause the moment you get...
The moment they stagger you, the point opens.
That's so tilted.
And they get like...
They get a point so fast.
Like, what the fuck?
Like...
It just feels like...
Yeah.
It just feels like the staggering...
The snowballing is like...
Even worse.
Yeah, it punishes...
It punishes you even more when you...
When you die too late.
I guess that's why.
Apparently they're thinking of...
They're thinking of making it so that...
Um...
You don't...
You can't get staggered because of the clash game mode.
Like, they're planning on changing it.
Um...
Yeah, it punishes you for inting without your team.
But like...
I can't fucking stop!
Stupid!
I was waiting for my take this entire time!
Um...
But like, I don't know if you guys heard.
But they were planning on removing staggering.
So like, the first person that dies triggers the respawn thing.
So like, the fifth person will respawn with the first person.
I don't know how I feel about that too.
Honestly.
I don't know how I feel about that.
Because like, there's been a whole strat about like...
It's like team play, you know?
Being able to stagger people.
Whoa!
Okay, I did not expect him to kill me that fast.
Alright.
Alright, I'll actually heal now.
For real.
Alright.
That's fucking right.
Maximum velocity, bitch.
Alright.
Nice.
Yeah, see, you literally win one fight and then you win the point.
There's like...
There's no way for them to...
There's no way for them to contest.
That's why I was like, eh.
That's how I feel about it so far.
It shouldn't be one fight and then automatically a point.
I feel.
Let's see.
Alright, where's my teams?
Where are they?
Where's the point?
Oh god.
Okay.
Like, okay.
Oh, nice, nice.
Nice for Matra.
What the fuck?
You just let him do that, Soldier?
Soldier, you just...
You just...
The thing about 2CP though, like, it's defense side.
It's the...
You can have, like, good...
You have... The respawn is literally right next to you.
So, like, it's not as...
I'm trying.
Oh, I tried.
I don't know if you saw me.
I was literally walking up to it.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh my god, you're still here?
Why are you still here?
Mercy, please.
Please, Mercy, please.
I just need you.
Oh, it's cause the point was right next to me.
Oh, that's why.
Okay.
I was like, why are you still here?
I'm gonna save this.
Okay, guess not.
Because somehow we're losing.
Oh, please.
This fuck... I'm mad.
I'm gonna kill this Reaper.
I'm mad now.
Juno has not enough DPS for me to kill this Reaper.
I'm fucking mad.
Bro, fuck this Reaper.
I wish it's not role queue so I can play DPS.
The damage is not enough.
Where are you?
Get out of here.
Get over here.
Get over here, Reaper.
I see you.
Good.
Alright.
There.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Where is the point?
Oh, it's back here.
Guys, the point is back here, guys.
We gotta get the point.
There we go.
Less mad now.
I am less mad.
I just needed to play Ana.
Alright.
There we go.
I still don't know how I feel about Juno so far.
I don't know.
Juno is definitely not a...
Not a main.
She doesn't feel...
Fuck you.
Yeah, that's fucking right, bitch.
God, you fucker!
Oh my...
Yeah, fuck you!
Hahaha.
Yes!
I already went this so much!
I...
I had the passion knock me off.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Everything is not going for Doki right now.
Everybody wants to kill Doki.
Holy fuck.
Anyway, I'm heading over, guys.
I'm still figuring out this map.
I'm heading over.
Just walk away from that!
Just walk away!
Oh.
Looks like they're not gonna be walking away.
Looks like.
I will fucking kill you.
Hahaha.
Or not.
I guess not.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna make it.
There we go.
Oh god.
Please.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
I'm kidding.
Everybody hates me.
Please, we have no heals.
We have no heals.
Please, survive!
Survive!
Please!
Just turn around!
I will kill this.
Reaper if it's the last thing I do.
Dude, fuck this Reaper though.
Please!
Somebody shoot anybody else!
Alright.
Apparently that was low ground.
I don't know how I got there, but okay.
Oh my god!
I swear to god.
Okay, I can literally heal here.
Alright.
I kept falling down.
Hahaha.
Because I didn't know where...
I didn't know where the...
Where it ends.
Please.
Why?
Why did you wake him up?
Guys.
No!
I swear to god!
Just touch him!
Hahaha!
Please.
You guys get on the point!
Get on the point!
It's literally...
Junkerqueen and she's 1 HP!
Alright.
Who poked him?
I hate it when people poke him.
He solo ulted me.
I hate him just as much as he hates me.
That's good to know.
Like, that makes me happy.
Knowing that.
Knowing that he also hates me.
Where are you?
I will kill every reaper I see.
I have ult already?
Jesus.
I was not expecting that.
I'm saving...
I'm gonna save this for when I see the reaper.
Oh, I see you.
I see you.
Kill him.
This sounds personal.
It is 100% personal.
There he is.
Alright.
Yeah!
I don't like this game mode.
I'm gonna fucking cry when it's in rank.
You know what?
It got me wanting to...
I wanna play damage.
We'll do damage!
And then we're gonna try out rank.
It's only game.
I gotta be mad.
When you have this one fucker.
When you have this... it's not.
Usually, Juno and Clash, it takes like two weeks.
Two weeks.
Oh, it is already in...
Oh, no.
It's already in rank.
No.
That sounds terrible.
Oh, no.
Are people okay?
Oh, alright.
Well...
I guess...
I guess we all just suffer.
I guess we just suffer, I guess.
I hated my rank.
I used to really hate...
eh..
eh,, push...
Now I can't believe there's a game that makes me hate...
What the fuck?
That makes me hate...
rank even more.
I can't believe it..
I can't believe they actually made a game world worse than PUSH.
That's so... that's impressive.
That's actually so impressive.
I think another issue with Clash is that the snowball doesn't stop.
You can't... like, in 2CP, you can stop the snowball.
Like, you... it doesn't... you know, you have two points.
Like, after defense, you do attack.
And then... but now... but now you have to deal with, like, a full snowball.
You know?
Alright.
Here we go.
Now I will be the Reaper.
I shall be the Reaper.
I don't remember how to play Reaper, but, like, I shall be the Reaper player now.
Alright.
Stupid idiot.
Now I'm the Reaper player.
Give me my HP.
I shall be cringe now.
I used to one-trick Reaper when the game first came out.
Not as good, though, but, like...
Let's see.
Okay.
Ooh, battery!
All charge!
All battery!
Whoa!
JK!
Hello!
Heal me now!
Oh, they went, like, full...
Maga cap... Maga mirrored?
God, that's boring.
Yay!
Come on, Juno!
That's fucking right!
I will be cringe now!
That's fucking right.
It's my turn to be cringe.
All right.
Sweet.
We just need... If we get that point, I guess we win.
Die!
Goodbye.
I do not want to be part of... part of this.
All right.
I'm gonna... flank now.
They were so fucking over-healed.
That was crazy.
I'm so fucking crazy.
There's no way.
No!
Where did the brick come
from?
That's so fucked!
Where did it come from?
It came from the sky!
Okay.
That's all right.
All right.
Let's see.
I just need to kill their support.
I think...
I think they swapped a bird because they were pissed off at me.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright.
I'm not sure what everybody is.
Alright, here we go.
Jesus Christ!
Okay, I gotta swap off Reaper now.
Woah, he...
Yeah, we do.
Okay, that's funny.
Easy.
Nice!
Fucking idiot.
Get better at the game.
Increase your game knowledge.
How did that work?
That's what separates me from you.
Alright, let's see.
Yeah, Reggie.
Reggie's gotta learn the game more.
Woah!
Hey there, buddy!
Hey!
Hey, buddy!
Chase me, I guess.
Holy shit.
Hey, sh... be able to...
Hey, buddy.
Hit those projectiles.
Oh!
Fuck!
I'm sorry!
Worth it.
I fucked that one guy in particular.
Alright.
I'm gonna still...
That poor man.
Yeah, I saw it.
I took the chance.
I...
I was like, you know what?
I wanna swap.
Fuck that one guy in particular.
Alright.
No more flanking.
Oh, no.
They're gonna snowball from that.
Woah.
No more flanking now.
I think I might die, though.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure, like, he's gonna fuck me up, man.
Oh, no.
No.
We're already staggered.
Woah!
What is this manga doing?
Soldier!
What the fuck are you...
Oh, my God!
You're still here?
That's it.
Now I'm super mad.
Why is he still there?
Alright.
Oh, he went Junkrat.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, my God.
Alright.
Oh, we're so staggered.
We gotta...
Wait!
We have to give...
We gotta give the point back!
We're so staggered now!
Don't go up!
Woah!
Goodbye.
I ain't goodbye.
I run.
Don't worry.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
Fucking stupid.
Oh, my God.
I've got to kilogramast.
I'm gonna just put the I'm killing this shit!
Look at this...
All right, What do you do?
Wtf?
Okay.
I think you guys were right in the middle of that.
I'm gonna stop shooting there.
Okay.
There we go.
Bye.
Oh god, oh no, we have zero support.
I'm heading there as fast as I can.
Don't worry, please heal me, please Juno.
Wait, where did our Juno go?
Juno, what do you mean?
Juno!
Oh, now you're alive!
Now!
Oh shit!
Alright, guys.
Guys, I don't know guys.
Oh, even he's like GG.
Game over.
One snowball is all it takes.
I did so much!
Oh, it's because I have a shitty DPS partner.
3k?
How?!
I was trolling!
How do you have less damage?!
I was blank!
Okay, now I play rank.
Now that I know how much hate I have in my life, I can play rank now.
Now that I know that my hate is justified, I can play rank.
And spread the hate.
Even more.
Alright, let me...
Let me put something on real quick.
Now that I'm in rank, it's time to lock it in, chat.
Since it's rank time, it's time to lock it in.
It's...
It's locked in time.
Sorry, I had to put my contacts in.
I...
I had to legally turn on my aimbot.
I had to turn on my aimbot right now.
We have aimbot on.
Now that we have legal aimbot, we can check this out.
Are they playing fucking Winston?
Oh my god.
Alright.
Alright, I know what to play now.
What are you doing?
Why are you on Winston?
What do you need to improve on?
As Winston.
Little bitch.
You're part of the problem.
That poor...
Whoa!
Okay, it's alright.
I wanted to play this character anyway.
Alright, Cam, it's over for you.
You have 13 kills.
How long have you been here?
Next time.
You did this.
Winston?
You did this, Winston.
Just so you know.
I could have been playing Cassidy.
But you are a problem.
Okay.
No!
He was one.
Parapete.
Pull up the cycle of abuse.
Where are you, Cam?
Where the fuck are you?
I'm here to fuck you up, Cam.
Oh, damn.
It's fine.
I gotta fuck this guy up too.
Yeah, D.Va!
Cringe!
Yeah, Cam.
That's right.
You did this, Cam.
You fucking did this.
I would have been happy.
That's right.
What are you doing?
I'm on your side!
Fucking idiot.
Look what you did.
Now you're a kill for me.
Stupid Venture.
I'm literally on your side.
I was literally trying to help you get rid of the monkey.
Alright.
Oh, he has ult for sure.
Yep, there he goes.
Let me farm.
I'll farm all of you.
I'll wait.
Take your aim, you idiot.
Oh, there we go.
Thank you.
He's gone now.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Now that he's gone...
Now that he's gone, I can actually play a character.
That's fine.
You must be like, really?
D.Va?
Really?
Yes.
Now I shall play the world of tanks.
Now they know what I had to go through.
They must be dealt.
They must know the pain I had to feel earlier today.
Yes, fuck you.
Right.
Run.
.
Cool.
Like D but it's...
.
He fucking left the game.
His bro mad.
.
I had to play against Winston in DM.
No!
Now there's MAGA!
I spit your poor soul!
Oh no!
I fucked up!
Now I have to play against MAGA!
I was gonna swap!
I swear!
I was gonna swap it!
This is your fault!
Oh yeah?
Now there's two MAGAs deserved!
What did it mean?
I was gonna swap!
Nobody killed me!
That's fucking right!
Now we all suffer!
If you swap, I swap!
Oh, he left the game.
Okay, I'm gonna swap now.
I don't really need this.
Now...
Now the world is at peace.
The world is now at peace.
Oh my god!
Isn't that great?
Peace has been restored!
I had to...
I had to do that!
For peace to be attainable!
What are you doing?
There you go!
Bye!
Where there's smoke, there's fire!
Alright, buddy.
You're good.
I'm gonna bully you in-game right now.
Bro, shoot your gun!
Please!
Oh...
I went through two sets of people!
I went through...
Are you fucking kidding me?
I went through two sets of...
Two sets of people!
Just...
Give me a game!
Oh my god.
Okay, another Juno.
Juno's not even the fun character for DM.
I don't understand.
Oh!
Fucking idiot!
Oh, come on!
And now there's another- Oh, thank god I got in!
I was like, are you serious?
Alright.
Here we go.
I don't even know.
Juno's in-game?
Wait, Juno's actually in-game?
Wait, there's no two weeks- What?
No way!
There's no two weeks buffer period?
She's in- Oh god, that sounds terrible.
Usually.
Oh, I thought you meant Clash was in it!
They actually put Juno as well?
Oh my god.
They don't do the grace period?
Usually it's like two weeks of grace period.
Alright.
Usually I would prefer two weeks grace period before you put Juno in.
She already had the buffer period?
That's not even a buffer period!
Usually you put two weeks.
It's like two full weeks.
That was one week!
Yeah, but the- Oh my god, that's weird.
That's weird.
That's fucking weird.
I don't like that.
Because that means like...
Day one of chaos.
It's literally day one of fucking rank chaos.
Right off the bat.
I don't know about that.
On video it looks like in whole This is a lot of non-sense but seriously, Don't make a hockey show.
It's crazy.
Holy fuck man.
Oh my god.
We got him.
He's from Canada.
I lovemara.
I love her so much.
Hey man.
We got the seal.
Okay you're something.
I saw it was the required.
That being said, Oh, hey!
He's dead though.
Oh, the ult charge is not that much.
I barely got ult charge because nobody took damage.
Has our Widow done anything?
Okay, he has.
That's good to know.
Are you serious?!
I didn't hit it!
Okay, usually that would smack somebody, but it didn't.
I'm just surprised it didn't smack anybody.
No!
Sorry, I'm not going to pay attention to you.
Please!
None of my nades hitting!
Everybody's getting smacked!
None of my nades are hitting!
You all get smacked away!
I have zero bionic nade kills!
It's fine.
I have so much heals.
Smack!
Are you fucking kidding me?!
Where's my smack?!
I'm mad now.
I started the ult.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, now I'm definitely whiffing.
Now I'm definitely whiffing.
For real.
It's happening.
I couldn't smack the nade.
What the fuck?
Oh.
Okay.
I saved him though.
Alright, it's orbit time.
Goodbye.
We leave.
We're gonna leave you.
There we go.
I did it!
I smacked!
Did you guys see the smack?!
Finally!
I smacked.
That's all I wanted in life.
I needed the smack there.
Alright.
Hey, guys.
I don't feel comfortable being here by myself.
Hey, guys!
Guys!
Where did everybody go?!
Hey!
Where did everybody go there?!
Guys, the cart's over here!
Hey, team!
Team!
Oh, we got it.
I'm fucking staying in the zone.
They don't need me.
By the time I walk over there, the thing will be over.
Taxi!
There we go.
Taxi.
Alright.
I'm back now.
I forgot that we had a Genji, not gonna lie.
I was like, oh yeah, I could do...
Nanoblade.
Winston is like really good.
I legitimately forgot we had a Genji.
Alright.
Okay.
I swear to God, if you wake him up, I will fucking cry.
Okay, he didn't wake him up.
That's good.
He didn't wake him up.
That's all I care about.
No cries.
No tears today.
Oh shit.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Will he die?
He'll be fine.
He'll be so fine.
Oh, never mind.
He's dead.
Oh!
That poor thing!
Oh, that was actually a misclick.
Whoops.
Oh no.
Please.
Alright.
He doesn't have...
Deflect!
No!
Goodbye.
Oh, I hit it!
No!
Oh, please.
Please.
No!
Oh shit!
Okay.
Oh, I hit it!
Oh shit, sorry.
I did a 360 there, so I missed.
Sorry.
Maybe I should have done a 360 so I could have healed you, Widow.
That is actually my bad.
That is my bad.
Oh, Winston.
Oh my God.
They went full Winston counter.
Oh god, Winton.
Winton, please.
We gotta push, we're so close.
Oh, I got you, Juno!
I got you!
I have to walk!
I don't have... you all have mobility except for me!
I don't have mobility!
Is that fair?
You all have mobility!
I'm just... I'm just a grandma!
What the fuck do I do?
Oh, he got cleansed.
That's not fair, too.
Goodbye, guys.
Boop him away!
Oh no.
Oh, we have the bubble.
He missed!
Yes!
Okay.
Oh no.
I tried.
Oh god.
Oh god, the reload.
Winton!
Winton, you're so good at this game!
Please!
You're so good at this game, Winton!
I don't know what's going on out there.
I was not... I was not ready for today.
Oh my god.
Okay, today is not a grenade day.
Today is definitely not a grenade day.
I have whiffed so many nades.
That's crazy.
I'm hitting shots, just not projectiles today.
No projectiles today for me, baby.
Today is just... My accuracy is pretty good.
I'm good accuracy.
It's just not nade day today.
Like, I mean, I'm doing good heals.
Just aim.
Like, I have literally the most heals out of both teams.
I just can't... I just can't fucking throw projectiles.
The nades are... The nades are in problem.
They are.
The nades are actually not good.
Okay, I just want to make sure I'm 280 hertz because sometimes it resets itself for no reason.
Oh, they went mora.
That's what I do.
There's a good Winston and I don't trust my team at all.
I just be like, fuck it.
All right, that definitely hit somebody.
I know that for sure.
Oh, shit.
Oh, god.
Bro, we're trying.
No, he threw a fucking wall.
Come back.
We need your help.
Winston.
Winston!
Oh, they're all anti!
They'll make an anti!
Oh, shit!
Juno, you and I.
You and I.
We heal each other!
Juno!
I thought we made a deal, you and I!
Juno please.
You and I.
I thought we made a
Winston literally just got ulted too!
That sucks!
Alright, I'm gonna go Kiriko.
I hate playing Ana against a Sigma.
Alright.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Use Symmetra.
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh god, you were in the sky!
I have to learn to look up!
I don't know if I'm ready for that commitment yet.
I don't know.
No!
This!
Winston!
Winston,
why didn't you beat me?
I just wanted to nano you!
Winston!
I just wanted to look at you!
Please!
You didn't look at us!
Winston!
Okay, I'm gonna stay near the Winston so I can fucking...
Alright, Winston.
Winston, please.
I'm gonna do this and then you're gonna do whatever the fuck you do there.
Alright, nice.
I don't think he's doing much with it.
Oh, I hear a Ventress.
Oh, he killed!
That's us!
Oh, that's a lot of ults, guys.
I don't know.
That seems a little overkill, guys.
That seems a little overkill.
We used like...
Oh, all of it.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, all of it.
That's fine.
We didn't need our ults.
I hear.
Alright.
I'm about to get shot in the back.
I can feel it.
Oh, shit!
I did that!
See?
Look!
I can hit that!
I did that!
Oh, my god.
I did that.
Smashed.
Yippee!
Yeah!
Get it down, grandma!
Let's fucking go, granny.
Show your asses, granny!
Is there a Mr. Anna?
Dude, he woke up.
Alright.
It'll be fine, right?
It'll be fine.
What are the moves?
A reaper?
Oh, they went for another reaper counter.
See?
Oh, they went hog.
Oh ho ho.
Angy.
Please, Symmetra.
He's so angy.
They went full fucking Winston counter.
I'm actually getting carried by this Winston.
Holy shit.
I'm gonna send a friend request.
Wait, do I?
That Winston is gaming.
Wait, where is he?
Whoops.
It's alright.
I didn't know you- oh.
That is not okay.
That is not okay right now.
Oh, that poor Ashe.
That poor fucking Ashe.
Holy...
That Ashe...
Oh shit, poor me.
Oh shit, okay.
Why did you wake him?
Okay, alright.
That's fine.
You have a...
That's okay.
Everything is okay.
Alright, nice.
One more minute of health.
Oh ho.
Oh ho, he definitely wants to ult.
There you go.
I knew... I knew I was fucking... I knew there was no hope.
I could tell.
I saw the Reaper rolling in.
And then I saw the entire team W keying into us.
And I was just like, alright, I'm out.
I'm out.
Oh, that AD spam though.
Alright, you should have walked backwards.
Like, through...
I... I don't know what he wanted.
Clearly.
I don't know why he didn't walk backwards there.
And kept fucking ADing.
Oh god.
Oh god, he's looking for the hook.
Alright, we're back in it.
Oh, please don't smack him into me!
I saw... I saw the red!
I saw the red in my life flashed!
I saw the... the flying Cassidy!
Holy shit!
Not the fucking flying Cassidy!
Oh my god, I thought it was over for me.
It was.
Guys, joke's on me, it was over for me.
It was over.
Oh my god, who would've thought?
Who would've thought it was over?
Okay, it went good.
We play for nano here, okay?
Okay.
Goodbye.
Guys, none of us touched point.
Guys, why did none of us touch point?
I got hooked!
I had an excuse!
I...
I... I literally got hooked!
What do you want me to do?
I... I don't know what they wanted me to do.
I got fucking hooked, man.
I... I...
I can't believe we see that.
I can't believe that our Winston is so fucking good.
And we actually probably had 21 games.
21 game damage!
Bro, what is our team doing?
Okay, I'm gonna go cute.
The thing is, if they go... I need to go Ana.
If they go hard, I have to play Ana.
Sad.
They have a hog again.
Holy shit.
Why is this my first game?
Why the fuck?
Like, what the fuck?
Our DPS also got really stag...
Like, our... their... their DPS is not doing so well.
But we got hella staggered and we're fucking around too much.
Our DPS was definitely fucking around too much earlier.
I feel like the moment they shut down our hog, it's over for our team.
We were relying too much on him.
Oh my god, please.
I had to...
I had to heal so many other people.
Oh god.
I have to reload, bro.
Okay.
That's fine.
That was a huge anti.
I have to reload.
There you go.
Oh, no!
I'm sorry!
That's actually...
Oh shit.
That's crazy.
Please get rid of him.
Please.
Please get rid of the Reaper.
He jumped!
Oh!
He actually...
Oh my god!
Oh no.
No, no, no.
Ashe, I'm gonna keep you up, but then...
You still don't have ult, Ashe?
How do you not have ult?
How do you...
How do you not have ult, Ashe?
Our Symmetra had ult!
How did he...
Oh, it's over.
Our Ashe did not have ult.
It's actually...
Oh my god.
No, I can't even swap.
I can't believe it.
He does not have ult.
How?
Oh, no.
I am just very surprised.
Out of everybody you expect to have...
Oh, I have to reload.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, our Juno didn't heal.
I had to...
Alright, he still doesn't have ult!
Oh my god!
What a full game!
We had to...
Holy shit!
He still doesn't have ult!
That's crazy!
How do you steal that ult after all of that?
Oh my god!
His ult was passively charged!
There's no way!
There's no way you don't have ult after all those games!
What is that Ashe doing?
Oh my god!
What the fuck is her fucking Ashe doing?
Spooks, thank you for...
joining the Tome of Fire!
Welcome back!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Spooks!
Yeah!
This Ashe still has no ult.
I cannot believe it.
It's actually...
I can't believe this Ashe still doesn't have fucking ult.
Bro!
Okay, he's not playing Ashe anymore.
He's playing Genji now.
Bro, I think he's more of a Genji player than an Ashe player.
That's for sure.
Alright.
I'm just gonna push.
We got the pick.
Alright.
Please.
Don't let him kill me.
Alright.
I mean, they have another fight from that.
So, it's not bad for them.
The Reaper's gonna...
Kill the Reaper.
But like, don't die.
Genji, please.
Genji, I literally have no angle.
He lives?
Oh, they went Winston.
Oh no.
No supports.
I'm trying!
I tried!
Nearly!
I hit you!
Oh my god!
I touched!
I did!
You just kept getting shot at!
Okay.
Why not?
Reaper
1!
Okay.
Please.
Keep me up.
That's all I want.
Thank you.
Alright.
Oh!
No!
Why didn't you wait yet?!
Oh my god!
Jesus!
That Tracer!
That Tracer actually woke him up!
I...
I hate my...
I hate my DPS.
I actually hate my DPS.
I don't want them ever.
I don't...
I don't want them ever on my team again.
There was zero.
Oh my.
I would have lived!
That's the thing!
No.
Fuck the other DPS too.
Who the fuck is this guy?
This guy was crazy.
I'm fucking sending a friend request and being like...
Oh my god.
I can't.
I'm gonna get insurance.
I'm fucking getting insurance right now.
I can't.
I can't fuck after that game.
Holy shit.
I...
I'm so...
I'm so fucking mad.
Holy shit.
I can't believe that happened!
I...
Sorry.
That...
If...
I'm just saying...
If like...
Oh my god.
If they didn't wake up the D.Va!
If they actually woke up the D.Va we actually could have got this.
I'm so fucking mad.
I...
Our Winston did so much.
I feel so bad for him.
He did so much.
And then this is the team we got.
I didn't even get Bob!
How do you not have Bob?
At any point of their lives.
At any fucking point of their lives.
We did not...
He did not deserve that.
He...
Oh my god.
I think I'm gonna add somebody real quick.
I need insurance.
I need...
I can't.
After...
After everything that happened I need a...
I need fucking insurance right now.
Usually I'm okay with solo queueing.
But that game...
That game fucking...
Oh my god.
That game tilted me so hard.
I fucking...
That was a 30 plus minute game.
That was actually a...
That was actually a 30 minute plus game.
Just for that to happen.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna fucking...
Oh...
This is...
This is a toxic relationship.
This is a toxic relationship with Overwatch.
I...
Let the hate flow.
That's basically it.
I'm letting the hate fucking flow into me right now.
Next game.
Next game guys.
Surely next game won't be that bad.
Oh yeah.
Surely like...
Next game will be okay.
And it's like...
It was not okay.
Oh my god.
Hey Doki, did you see Deadlock?
How much toxicity do you think he'd come from a FPS MOBA?
Skylam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not say anything.
Deadlock?
What's that?
What's Deadlock?
Never heard of it.
Never heard of it before.
Alright.
It's insurance time.
Here we go.
Alright.
We have rank insurance.
Oh my god.
I wish...
Guys, I don't think that Winston wants to be my friend.
I don't...
I don't think that Winston wants to be my friend.
Guys.
I'm so sad.
I don't know why.
Why don't they want to be my friend?
Bro, what the fuck?
Why is this all?
This is Space Battle.
This is fucking Star Wars.
But like...
Post Disney Star Wars.
Fuck it.
I'm fucking going into Space Battle time.
Space Battle time.
That's fucking... what are you gonna do with that?
Nothing!
Oh, you got super shit!
That's fucking right!
That's embarrassing!
Oh no, that's embarrassing for me.
JKA.
Jesus Christ.
Whoa!
Yeah?
Yeah, I fucking see you!
That's fucking right!
Where are you?
You wanna... do it with me too?
Oh, that's fucking...
Yeah!
Hey!
Oh shit!
Okay!
Never mind.
Never...
He actually hit his first shots.
Isn't that crazy?
He actually did it.
Good for him.
Who fucking is playing Cassidy?
In the Space Wars!
In the fucking Space Wars!
What are you doing?
This team will buy you!
The last remaining non-Disney IP.
It's Cowboys vs.
Aliens.
On solo lore accurate.
Holy fuck.
Here we go.
Oh, he's not Widow anymore.
Oh, that is...
That is so embarrassing.
Oh, fuck!
What?
Alright.
Now everybody's Cassidy?
What happened?
What?
Why are we all Cowboys now?
Alright, now I wanna be a Cowboy.
Okay.
Yeah, I win.
Oh, no.
When did the meta swap?
I thought we were all gonna be...
Easy.
That's why the meta swapped.
Oh, my God.
They went back to the past.
It's Cowboys vs.
Aliens.
It's actually...
Who will win?
I think the Cowboys are winning, guys.
Except for one guy.
All the Junos.
The Junos are like...
The Junos are just farming each other.
What the fuck is this guy?
Pussy!
No!
Fucking pussy.
They got into it.
Oh, my God.
The space Cowboys.
Alright.
I swear to God.
If you fucking play Juno, you're throwing this way to fucking God.
Maybe that's why I lost.
Alright.
It can't be that bad.
Surely.
Surely, it can't be that bad, right?
Surely, this will be better.
We don't...
Maybe Surprised Juno is overpowered.
Juno just has a lot of stuff.
Okay.
I don't know.
I feel like nobody has figured out how to play Juno yet.
I feel...
That's the thing.
I feel like...
People don't know how to...
I mean, she literally just came up today.
Rank wise.
So, I will not be surprised if no one really knows how to play her mechanic.
Is that Widow?
Oh...
It'll be fine.
I believe.
Oh.
I'm not fine.
Please.
PLEASE!
HE'S COMING BACK!
Oh no.
Oh my god.
He came back!
Yeah!
Guys, I might need to refund the insurance.
I might need to...
Oh my god.
That is a nasty shatter.
I basically... I basically fucked his charge up.
I took the sleep kill.
Alright.
I'm gonna go up here.
I guess I'll nano the Ryze.
I don't think we have enough healing.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, Ryne, please.
No, Ryne, please.
Oh, hey guys.
Guys, don't you wanna contest the point?
Guys, fight our point so we can grab extra tanks!
Okay, I don't know.
Oh, man.
Oh, Ryne.
I think their Ryne's better.
Guys, I think... I have a feeling that their Ryne's better than our Ryne's.
I don't know.
After that...
After what I just saw...
Yeah.
If I nano the Ryne...
Watch this.
We're gonna get shattered.
Oh, we did it.
I'm surprised we didn't get shattered there.
Usually when you nano the Ryne, the Ryne just shatters people.
Please.
Guys, please.
Guys, please!
Please!
Please, guys.
Oh, my god.
Holy shit.
I don't understand.
Why is their Ryne peeking their healer?
But our Ryne...
Our Ryne's like, fuck that.
There you go.
I am giving the heals.
Oh, please.
I have to reload.
Oh, no.
No!
Calypso!
Okay.
I'm a little scared that Ryne's going in.
Oh, nice.
I got the anti.
Alright, this game...
This game, I'm doing a lot of anti's now.
I figured...
Ryne, please!
Please, Ryne, please!
Please!
He still has shatter, too.
That's the thing.
He still has shatter.
Oh, no.
He's coming.
He's coming over.
Guys, I'm scared.
Guys, I'm very scared.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, there was a...
You know what?
I...
I dropped down.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Where did the Torbjorn come from?
Holy shit, Ryne.
I need you to go jump.
I need you to touch it, Ryne.
Do your thing.
I'm on it.
I'm gonna...
Not done!
Okay.
Alright.
I love Overwatch.
This guy needs to live.
This guy.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Guys, I think it's time to hang up Ryne.
You're not him.
You're not him, bro.
Bro, Orisa, you're not him.
I'm sorry, bro.
You're not.
Alright.
We can do this with Orisa.
I believe.
Guys, I love Overwatch.
Guys, it's...
such a good game.
I can quit anytime I want.
I...
I can quit anytime.
How?
How are you still...
Why are you still doing this?
I...
Okay, I'm fucking playing.
You're right.
Nevermind.
How...
How are you still like this?
How are you...
You're literally...
Guys, I can quit anytime I want.
Chat.
I can stop playing this game anytime I want.
Alright?
I don't have a problem.
There you go.
Okay, thank God.
Alright.
That's one pick, guys.
That's one pick.
Guys, he's anti.
This is all we needed.
Here we go.
That's all we needed.
Alright.
Okay.
He should have shatter now.
There's no way he doesn't.
He should have shatter.
This Rein has been doing a lot.
I thought he was gonna... I timed it wrong.
I thought he was gonna...
Alright.
Run.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
That's good.
Please keep Orisa alive.
Just keep him alive.
Save the Orisa.
That's good.
I almost used nano.
But it was no use.
That's good.
I didn't use nano.
I almost used it.
But I did not.
That's good.
I didn't use nano.
I'm so happy I did.
The Cassidy killing me was like the best decision he ever made.
Okay.
He definitely has shatter for real this time.
I'm fucking not getting close to that.
Oh god.
There we go.
That's a shatter.
That's a shatter right there.
He wants to...
I still walked into it.
I even knew he was going to do it.
I was like, oh there it is.
This is going to happen.
I even walked into it.
I was like, there it is.
I think at that point I just accepted it.
I was just like, oh.
This is weird.
I'm going to get shattered.
There's no point.
Guys.
There's no point living.
I knew it was going to happen regardless.
No matter what I do.
I was going to get hit.
There was no saving me there.
There was no saving me.
Okay.
We got the...
We got the ride.
We literally got the ride.
That's good.
I embraced.
I embraced it.
Where did he come from?
Where the fuck did he come from?
It's okay.
We have literally one fight.
Please Orisa, do not use your ult.
We have one fight left.
We need you to go.
We need someone to go Lucio.
Go Lucio.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Alright.
I literally went left because I thought he was going to go left.
But then he went right?
Alright.
Okay.
I didn't get hit.
Please.
Orisa.
Why...
Why do they always run away?
I don't understand.
I'm avoiding...
I'm avoiding this.
I'm avoiding this Ana.
No not Ana.
That's me.
I'm avoiding myself too.
I'm avoiding this Orisa.
Why does he keep... Why does he keep running away?
Why did you keep running away?
Oh my god.
I swear, I'm gonna use voice comms if I get another fucking tank like that.
I swear to god.
I'll use my voice comms and be like, FUCKING PEEK!
I can't.
I fucking can't.
I'm gonna fucking use voice comms so I don't have to deal with that again.
Thank you.
This is not scrims.
Or was it skirmish?
This is not skirmish.
I've never...
From...
From having a fucking amazing Winston player, to dealing with one of the most dogshit tank players.
Oh my god.
I can get top 500 this season.
Wanna bet?
Paladin Knight?
I bet you I can get top 500 this season.
I didn't have time to really grind out this last season because...
I had to move and everything.
Alright, bet.
What do I get if I get top 500 this season?
What do I get?
Yeah.
Bet?
I bet you guys I can get top 500 this season.
Easily.
Where's Paladin Knight?
Paladin Knight!
What do you wanna bet?
You promise not me.
Yeah?
Bet!
Oh.
Bitch.
What the fuck?
You can shoot your toes?
He shot me in the toes!
That's a...
Idiot.
That's a fucking idiot.
Fucking idiot.
He kept trying to shoot me through the fucking...
Alright.
There was no way I was gonna live there.
There was no way.
Oh my god.
Bro, fuck off.
Bro, what the fuck?
Oh shit!
That's so fucked!
And he missed!
He fucking missed.
That's embarrassing.
He actually missed.
That's fucking right.
You missed that.
Yeah, fucking sleep dart.
Sleep dart now.
Bitch.
Sleep dart now, bitch.
Oh, okay.
Oh my god.
What do we get if we don't Doki?
I don't have to tell you because like I'm gonna get it.
Yeah, you might as well just give me the prize now.
Oh my god that instant lock Mercy.
I'm not- fuck this.
Actually no, I don't want to throw.
I don't want to throw.
Alright.
I like you, Kappa.
The sun is in a new location today.
Oh, like this?
Is that not where it was before?
That's not how bets work.
Well, this bet is obviously I'm gonna win this bet.
That's basically it.
I'm obviously gonna win this bet, guys.
So all I'm saying is that you might as well just reward me now.
Chat.
You might as well.
I can get top 500 this season.
It'll be so easy.
I have the- I don't have the time.
But like I have more time than before.
Before I had- I had to move and everything.
But now, now I have the time.
Jesus Christ.
Usually I'm not here, but like I'm scared for a Winston.
Honestly.
I'm actually so scared for a Winston.
Alright.
No!
Winston!
I got body blocked by my fucking fat DPS players!
Okay.
God damn it.
God fucking damn it.
Where the fuck is my Winston?
There he is.
There you go.
Guys, I killed our Ashe.
Easy.
There you go.
Wait, I killed my duo.
Whoops.
I forgot my duo was the Ashe.
Alright.
Hehe.
Nice.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything is awesome.
Ba-da-da-da-da.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da.
Keep an eye out.
Oh.
I hear people walking up.
Winston!
Oh my god.
Guys, I think I hate...
I think I hate my Winston player.
Guys.
I think...
I think we have a very bad Winston today.
You think he can touch it?
There's no way.
He fucked it up already.
Yeah, I hate it.
I didn't even need to...
I already could tell.
I could tell he was gonna not...
I saw him hit the...
I saw him hit the fucking...
The wall up there.
And I was like, yeah, you're not.
You're not gonna make it.
I timed it already.
Oh god, please.
I don't wanna fucking heal, but I wanna shoot.
Alright.
Here you go.
Winston!
I can't save you, my buddy.
My man.
Bro.
I can't.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Like...
I cannot save you, bitch.
I can't.
Me pee with bath.
Me pee with...
Our Mercy literally has 6k healing.
Our...
Our Mercy.
This is...
This is not an Overwatch day, I feel like.
Oh my god.
Winston.
Yet again.
Winston, please.
Alright.
Guess I die here.
I die here.
Maybe I need a third!
Maybe I need the third to play tank!
I...
I think.
I think I need to grab a second insurance just to play tank.
I...
I said.
I'm being beaten by someone else!
I feel like I'm being played by terrible tanks right now.
So he gave me that one...
OH MY GOD!
WHAT DID I DO?
Like, what do we do?
I couldn't even heal him in time.
Bro, you're not him!
You're actually not him!
Holy shit.
Oh, fucking hell.
Jesus Christ, I might as well learn fucking Juno at this point.
I need a tank and a DPS.
The first game was like a tank and a DPS issue.
Now we're having tank issues.
Like, no amount of healing is gonna fucking save him.
I swear to God, Wynton, I...
I swear to God, Wynton.
Oh, thank God, at least he got somebody.
Oh my god.
Please.
Wynton, you're a little bit too up ahead.
You're a little bit too ahead.
I...
I don't like that.
I really don't like that.
You're so...
You're so ahead.
Fuck it.
Two alts.
I don't trust... I don't trust team.
I don't trust team.
I... I don't trust the team.
Oh my God, I hit my head up.
Alright.
Wynton, please.
Please.
I swear to God, if we lose this, I'm grabbing a third plate.
I...
They have Reaper.
Oh God.
Okay.
Please.
Why?
Why, Wynton?
Oh my God.
Actually, why?
Why?
Why did he do that?
What is Bro doing?
What is he doing?
Oh God.
Please.
I'm trying.
No!
Oh God, I didn't want to get crushed.
I could tell I was going to get crushed.
At least Wynton...
Wynton is the lead.
Oh, he has ult.
That Reaphras ult, though.
No!
Repress all!
I can feel the all!
Oh god.
Are you fucking...
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna DM a tank player.
I can't.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna DM a tank player.
My sanity cannot take this anymore.
I cannot take this anymore.
Oh my god.
I can't.
He's still playing Winston.
He's actually...
Rage bait.
Oh my god.
Holy fuck.
How am I supposed to heal when he's fucking killing himself non-stop?
Holy shit.
You're fucking terrible at tanks.
You want more hands?
Damn, I play Life Weaver.
I fucking play Life Weaver, you whore.
Bro, you're literally the worst fucking tank today.
I cannot heal you when you're always trying to kill yourself.
Like...
Oh my god.
If that's what he wants...
Oh, yeah!
Let me fucking heal!
Let me heal bot!
Yeah!
Heal bot!
Let's go!
Whoa!
Oh, sorry.
I was too busy healing.
You want me to do something about it?
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
Okay.
Like I said, I can't heal stupid.
Alright.
Here, have a fucking lotus.
Have a lotus.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh, no one wants to take my flower.
Whoa!
Yeah!
Is that enough heals for you, you fucking whore?
Whoa!
Yeah!
I'm fucking dead.
There's nothing I can do.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Fucking hell.
I'm gonna fucking plant a tree.
Oh, wait.
What am I doing?
I'm left-clicking.
Fucking hell.
Go in.
I swear to god, you don't go in after I planted a tree.
I swear to god.
I've literally gave you guys a tree.
I... I don't know what you want.
I gave you a fucking tree.
I...
We just needed to walk forward.
Oh, shit.
Insane Winston player.
Oh my god.
Fucking feeding your ass out.
And then blaming the support because...
Whoa!
I'm not getting heals.
No way.
Right?
Oh, you finally realized that Winston wasn't it?
You fucking finally realized that?
Wow.
Damn.
We're losing anyway.
Thank god placements don't matter.
Thank god.
Yippee.
It would be funny if I killed him.
Alright.
Woooo.
Oh, hey.
Too bad.
Well.
What if I pull my duo back to me?
I want that payload.
Slash character.
Oh my god.
That's actually crazy.
I took it one for that.
That's absolutely insane.
You got me out of business.
I'm full.
Charged.
Oh, now he talks?
Holy fuck.
Oh, now he talks.
This is not winnable.
Like, I wanna like just walk off the cart.
There's the fucking tree.
There you go.
There's the tree.
Stand near the tree.
Oh, thank god.
I'm out.
I'm out of this game.
Oh, my god.
Holy fuck.
You fooled me.
Oh, god.
Guys, I think... I think Overwatch might be the worst game.
I think...
I think Overwatch might be like one of the worst games right now.
True, but I can't stop playing.
That's the worst part.
Oh hey, it will not be placed on your team.
Players are normal.
Oh, they made a new thing for it.
That's actually awesome.
I like that a lot more.
Wait, where's mine?
Wait, can I avoid like 12 people now?
Oh no, this is pinned.
Wait, I thought I... Oh, okay.
It's okay.
They avoided me so I don't have to waste my avoid slots.
Guys, they avoided me so I don't have to waste my avoid slots.
Please.
Oh my god.
No, there's no way.
There's no way he didn't.
He played me and then just...
He played me.
I just killed a Juno!
Who is this?
Am I going to have to kill another Juno?
Oh, thank god you're not Juno.
I'm just happy you're not.
I literally killed a Juno and then another Juno popped out.
Guys, Overwatch may be really bad right now, but I can quit any time.
Chat.
Guys, I can quit any time.
I...
Why is it... Why?
I hate the Space Wars.
No time to waste.
Guys, I can... I can play other video... I can play other competitive games.
Well, I can't quit right now, guys.
I gotta get top 500.
We made a bet.
But like, after that, I can quit any time.
After that.
After that, I can quit any time I want.
Guys, I...
I don't have a problem.
I don't have a problem, guys.
No!
Yeah.
I can quit whenever I want, guys.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh my god, and there's a Zenyatta?
Bro!
Fuck off!
That's embarrassing.
Oh, here.
There's my tumbleweed.
That was embarrassing for that Juno.
Poor Tyler.
I can do it.
It's that easy.
Like... Like, I can do it.
Yeah, see?
I totally believe you.
Yeah!
Cause I can!
Bro, this Kiriko has been the bane of my existing... existence.
I finally killed her, but only because she was half HP.
I have not been able to kill this fucking Kiriko for so long.
My kill.
Yoink.
My kill, too.
Oh, my kills.
My kills.
Oh.
Oh shit!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I'll just go back here.
Oh, my god.
I swear...
NO!
Yes!
Okay.
All right, finally.
I beat him with full merit.
Hey!
Oh, shit!
This is fucked up.
I can't believe he stole my kill!
Who would... what kind of fucked up person does that?
What kind of fucked up person would do that to somebody?
Somebody will show up.
Wait, I'm so fast.
Oh my god, I was so fast there.
I know they did that for the elf.
Watch this.
Damn.
Damn, that's fucked.
Who would ever steal kills?
Who would ever do such a thing?
That's so fucked.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Guys, I need you guys to chill.
What?!
I'm so fast!
That's unfair!
That's actually fan art.
Fair.
Oh my god.
How could they do this to me?
I made my mistakes.
Alright, let's see.
Life will be different now.
Life would be so diff- This is it.
This is the moment my luck changes.
This is it.
That's when you know I'm playing Mora.
My third...
He's shopping right now.
It's like, can you play take?
He was like, I'm outside.
I had to buy stuff.
I messaged the fourth.
I messaged the fourth, so we'll see.
We'll see if God likes me today.
I think today is just not my day.
I think.
I...
I think today is just not my day.
Not gonna lie.
It's just... How?
Oh my god.
It's not fair.
They gave me like...
What world was like with a good tank.
And now I don't know how to live.
Live like this anymore.
They gave me what life was like.
If my tanks were decent.
For like one game.
That's so cruel.
Life is so cruel.
And he's literally playing Orisa.
Which is like the doom counter.
Like that...
Life is so fucking cool, man.
He's low.
I was gonna say he lives.
He does not live.
Alright.
Let's see.
On him.
Genji, please.
Don't die.
I don't have anything left.
Oh, dude.
Why are you fucking kidding me?
Dude.
Hahaha.
Oh, beyond point.
This is fucked.
Because...
Alright.
Alright, Juno.
You heal me, I heal you.
Alright, nice.
We did it, guys.
We did it.
Alright.
Remember this girl died to a stone baby 14 times in a row.
She literally killed a baby and couldn't even...
That's me.
That's me, guys.
And I am not proud of it.
Fuck this guy.
Guys, please.
Move up.
Please.
I beg of you.
We double supported all and we didn't get anything?
Okay.
Hahaha.
Why did nobody moved up?
I don't understand.
Oh my God.
I don't understand why none of us moved up.
It's just not those days.
It'll be fine.
Nice.
Okay.
Sadly, that was not nice.
That was sadly not nice.
Please.
He's literally one.
Why am I on point?
I'm literally on a...
I'm just a fucking grandma.
Why would you do this to granny?
Hahaha.
Alright.
Yeah?
He missed?
How do you miss?
Fuck this.
Okay.
Hahaha.
Alright.
This is...
This is the game.
Hahaha.
This is...
Wait.
Has our Doom ever ulted?
Oops.
Here I go.
I can't even position myself.
Nobody's touching point.
Oh.
He has six...
Hahaha.
Holy fuck.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Despair.
This is full rank reset.
So I don't know.
Or half reset.
Hahaha.
I don't know.
Oh my...
Hahaha.
Dude is 4-6.
Dude is playing Doomfist!
I can't believe it.
Dude is playing Doomfist against Orisa.
You know what's sad?
That guy I added never added me back.
Because I think he thinks I'm...
He's like...
Oh great.
Another.
Hahaha.
Oh.
You're 5.
Oh shit.
Sorry.
Oh.
He got saved from the fucking...
From the wall.
From the ceiling.
Okay.
I can finally fucking position myself now.
Thank fucking god.
Oh.
And now they have Sombra?
Yeah.
Fuck our Doom I guess.
Our Doom's not...
Let's have Doom not do anything even more.
Hahaha.
Let's make sure he's never alive.
Really?
There's no need to counter our Doom.
He counters himself perfectly fine.
Hahaha.
Like...
Why?
He literally counters himself.
Why did you blink away from the heals?
Fine.
I was not gonna live there.
I was literally...
Oh my god.
He finds...
He wins Zarya!
Hahaha.
He wins Zarya.
No.
This is counter swap.
It's team counter swap day.
No.
Hahaha.
They're gonna be counter swapping all day.
No.
Please.
Hit one shot.
Hit one hook.
That's all I want.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Believe.
I believe.
Oh god.
I don't believe anymore.
Alright.
We have Pharah.
Okay.
Here we go.
Hahaha.
It's pharmacy time.
It's pharmacy.
Why did he blink D.Va?
He couldn't blink D.Va.
Hahaha.
He doesn't even hit hooks.
You don't...
Oh.
I didn't...
You're gonna...
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
We're all counter swapping today.
I see.
Let's all counter swap.
It's really like...
With a whole...
Maybe we should even swap Juno.
Maybe Juno is the problem.
We swapped everything.
Hahaha.
Guys.
Maybe Juno is...
Oh my...
No.
Maybe Juno is the problem.
They have no tank.
No tank.
Please.
I will use this.
I don't trust my entire team anymore.
Roll dice.
Oh my god.
The first hook he's got.
I am trying my best to make sure you don't die.
Oh my god.
He actually hit a hook.
It doesn't matter though.
Hahaha.
It actually doesn't matter.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Guys.
We win.
We would win a game.
We will win a game.
I believe.
Hahaha.
Jesus Christ.
We will win a game.
We will.
I believe.
Hahaha.
It can't be that bad.
There's no way.
Hahaha.
Next game will be better.
Oh hey.
You don't hit...
Oh.
Alright.
Hey.
Hog.
You don't...
You don't wanna walk up?
Hahaha.
Oh.
Okay.
I...
Hahaha.
Oh.
Okay.
He's playing tank now.
Hahaha.
We're at this point.
Why are we...
Hahaha.
Maybe...
Maybe I'll message a DPS player and see him there.
Hahaha.
Maybe message another DPS player.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
No.
It hurts.
It actually hurts.
Hahaha.
Do Overwatch players feel joy?
No.
Of course not.
Hahaha.
I really think they're happy playing this.
It's just a toxic relationship.
We just can't leave.
We can't fucking leave.
Hahaha.
It's been a lot.
It's cause like we...
We used to be really happy.
And then we're always trying to chase that high of what it was like when we were happy.
So like...
We're always like maybe it'll be different this time.
You know?
Maybe like this time it'll be different.
And then like...
Yeah.
You start...
Like...
You try to chase that same happiness again.
You know?
Hahaha.
You're just...
You're just like...
It'll be different this time.
I'm gonna get ice cream.
I can't.
I'll be right back.
I can't keep doing it.
There's no way.
This...
This game will be different.
There's no way.
I have ice cream now.
There's no fucking way.
I...
Hahaha.
There's no fucking way.
I have ice cream now.
Things will be...
Things are looking up.
Things are looking up now.
Oh, hey.
Okay.
Hmm.
I have Moki.
Oh.
Hahaha.
I will be the problem.
Hahaha!
I'm gonna be the reason why we live now.
haha!
Hahaha!
Haha!
Be the problem so no one else can be defined.
Hahaha!
I remember this place.
I know this is where I learned not to drink soy sauce.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, if I'm the problem...
If I'm the problem, then like... then you can blame me.
We tried so hard.
Oh shit!
I might be dead.
Oh, oh no!
Okay.
Okay, now that I took Juno from everybody...
Now that I took Juno from everybody...
They won't... nobody can pick Juno now.
Now that I took Juno...
Now...
They cannot take Juno.
That was my plan all along.
That was how we're gonna do it.
Oh shit!
Please, Bat, please turn around!
Please get the turret!
There we go, we figured it out.
I take Juno first...
I die with Juno...
And then I swap.
We figured it out.
We fixed the problem.
We...
We fixed it.
This is how we fix Overwatch.
I cracked the code.
It's okay, I fixed the problem.
He has shatter.
Like...
There we go.
Problem solved.
I fixed the problem by becoming the problem.
That's how you do these things.
Oh god.
Can they touch it?
No, they can't.
Oh!
They wasted ult too!
Technically, they didn't waste ult because...
Technically, they don't because they can still snowball this.
Oh, they can't anymore.
Wow!
There's another door...
Alright.
Yeah, but if I...
If I die before...
After the bat, it'll be fine.
Oh, I don't think we can make it.
Can we make it to the other side?
They like push this so far.
Oh shi...
Okay.
But we have ult though, so...
Oh, nevermind.
No, they definitely got this.
Oh, they snowballed us.
No, they snowballed us.
Oh, we can't win.
We're doing it.
I'm a pro.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, we're staggered now.
No!
He went judo!
That's not what's supposed
to...
Oh, no.
The Avenger booted me into them even more.
No!
You're not supposed to be judo!
I thought I fixed it!
How did I not fix the problem?
Julius took over.
No, we still... there's still hope.
Okay.
Okay, I was scared.
I was so scared.
Alright, nice.
God, I hate Clash.
Ooh, that was a good anti, though.
Are you fu... Oh, God, I thought he was gonna let his shield down because he was gonna do a... do that.
No!
I thought he was gonna let these... I thought he was gonna fucking swing his hammer first.
Alright.
It's okay.
We're fine.
I might be getting bullied, but we're okay.
Our team is doing great.
A091842... wait, is that... is that Aimbot Calvin?
Is that Aimbot Calvin?
That's... he's the only one that I know that has this username, or if that's a troll.
Oh, goodbye.
Yay!
Okay.
I gotta reload.
I'm sorry.
He missed!
And he's anti!
He's won!
Go do the thing!
He's anti!
Shoot him!
Oh, my God, we did it.
We fucking did it.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, we fucking did it.
Holy shit, that's all we needed.
We need an actual tank.
We need an actual tank player.
We need...
Holy fuck.
Oh, my God.
We just needed a fucking human being.
I'm gonna keep doing that.
I'm gonna pick Juno, and then I'm gonna swap off.
And we're just gonna have the Ice Cream Titus thing.
That's all I needed.
That's all I fucking needed in life.
Oh, my God.
We cracked the system.
Okay.
I cracked the code.
The Ice Cream Buff.
I should've just had Ice Cream in the beginning.
Honestly.
Please.
Oh, my God.
I hope...
I hope you never find happiness.
I fucking know you're coming here.
Oh, my God.
I hope you...
I hope you stub your toe.
I think deserved.
Actually deserved.
That match made me a lot happier.
That actually made me a lot happier.
Why do I always bump into you?
It's actually...
That's fucked.
That is so fucked.
I wanna fight other people.
There's so many other people in this world.
Oh, thank God he left.
Thank God.
Are you really...
Are you serious?
I...
Why do I keep bumping into either the Orisa or the Venture?
Can I fight real people?
Can I...
Oh, my...
Thank fucking God.
The one time I fight a real person.
The one time I fight a human being.
Oh, my God.
That's actually...
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck are you doing?
The one time I fight a real person.
What the fuck?
I hear footsteps.
Fuck you!
Stop pepper spraying me!
You're bad!
Keep pepper spraying!
You're not gonna kill me!
Oh, maybe she is.
I think she might actually.
JK.
Come on!
Fucking right!
There you go!
Are you happy?
Are you fucking happy?
Okay.
Okay, bitch.
Oh, wait.
You're not entertained.
Oh, at least he's not playing Juno.
That's...
Oh, my God, from...
from...
from Clash to Push.
Alright.
Are you...
The...
They got tricked.
Are you fucking...
Oh my god, fucking a trick.
I can't believe they fucking tricked me.
I let my guard down.
I let my guard down for one second.
For one fucking a second.
I was like, he didn't pick Juno!
I didn't have to insta-lock Juno!
The fact that he didn't insta-lock Juno and I was like...
Don't have to worry.
What the fuck, Reaper?
Right off the bat?
Jesus Christ, that poor guy.
Will you heal me, Juno?
No, you just wanna be...
That's fine.
That's fine, I don't...
I don't need to be healed, guys.
Here we go.
Please.
Please, no.
SHOOT ME!
Hahahaha!
Okay.
It's fine.
We're fine.
We're gonna go Bora the moment I ult.
Alright, it's fine.
We don't talk about Juno, no, no, no, no.
I don't know like...
I don't know what goes well with Juno.
I think if I figure out what the fuck goes well with Juno...
Like, this would be a lot easier.
But like, everybody is still meta-crafting.
Oh, hey, Juno.
This is what it's like to...
Oh.
Well, you had two people shooting you.
Like, I'm sorry.
Alright.
He had...
Oh, he definitely has pause.
Yeah!
I was gonna say.
That's why I like, got away.
Because I was like, oh, he has pause.
Alright.
Here we go.
Untamed power!
Where's our Juno?
Juno!
Oh, non-existent.
That's...
Yeah.
Yeah, Reaper L2.
Hey, Juno.
Can you...
Juno, can you, you know...
No!
That's fine.
Hey, that's what it's like to...
To have a healer.
Alright.
Let's...
Let's play more.
Oh, boy.
Alright.
It's okay.
It is more a tab.
The Juno will learn what healing is like soon.
I believe.
They have Reaper L2.
That's why I'm like...
I don't know what the fuck is he...
Oh.
Alright.
That's fine.
That's okay.
Alright, we're fine, guys.
The Juno's healing again.
Guys, the Juno's healing!
We're so fine!
Like, I'm not as sad anymore.
It's fine.
He's healing!
Yeah.
That's all I wanted from my Juno.
Oh shit, I couldn't get to him in time.
Like, I debated about using my shit, but then I was like...
I was like, I don't know guys.
Alright, come on.
He doesn't... I don't even know if he has shift.
Oh, I have shift though.
That's fine!
It's... oh!
Alright.
This is a little concerning that... you know...
Oh, that is still...
No!
Please just heal our Maga!
Keep him alive!
Keep... oh!
There was nothing we could do.
There is nothing we could do.
Holy shit.
We need our own Reaper.
We must stop the enemy from advancing.
Okay, wait.
Nice, I did it.
What the fuck?
What is he doing behind us?
I did something very dumb there.
And then everybody dropped down as well, like...
I was just surprised that everyone dropped down with me.
I was very surprised.
I did not expect people to drop down.
Alright, here we go.
What do we do?
Nope, goodbye.
Oh, what?
How did he not instant die?
Wait, what?
Oh.
That's...
Oh, he's dead.
Sorry, bro.
No!
Oh, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Two people died anyway.
Oh my god.
How the fuck...
How the fuck did the Cassidy not instant die?
I was so surprised there.
Alright.
Maybe I should...
That's the thing.
I was thinking about Kiriko.
But I feel like if I go Kiriko, we might not have enough heals.
Kiriko's healing output is not the best.
And I could just use for her invuln.
Okay.
Where did he come from?
Where did...
I...
Okay.
Okay, that's...
Alright.
He...
He deserves that.
He fucking...
He deserved it.
Oh my god.
He deserves that one.
He...
He's a gamer.
Guys, he...
Games so fucking hard.
He...
Alright.
Come on.
I'm poking people.
I'm poking at so many people.
You know, sometimes you're just not meant...
Sometimes, today just wasn't it.
Today just wasn't the Overwatch day.
It's cause I forgot to do the... I forgot to do the Juno strat.
It's the Juno strat.
It's legitimately...
It's...
It's the Juno strat.
I need to pick Juno first.
Like...
That's it.
The moment I don't pick Juno, I...
It's actually...
It's actually... Please Tracer, we need you to get back in.
I did the Juno strat and then we won.
Like, legit.
That's all we need.
That's all we fucking need.
We just...
That's like... That's the...
That's the... The way to win.
You pick Juno and then you swap off.
That's basically it.
Alright.
Honestly...
I might be dead here.
Oh yeah, 100% the Kiriko fell too.
Maybe I just need ice cream.
Maybe that's it.
Maybe I just need fucking ice cream.
Maybe...
Maybe that's it.
I need ice cream.
I need...
Okay.
Don't cry, please.
Don't cry!
Okay.
Okay, buddy.
I don't know, man.
Oh, what?
What happened to it?
Wait, what happened to the pulse bomb?
What the fuck?
What happened to the pulse bomb?
Did I cleanse it?
I didn't cleanse it.
Did I?
Bro, I can't tell.
I'm so fucking out of it right now.
I...
There's no...
What do you wanna do, cleanse it?
I wasn't...
You shit her!
Oh my god.
He fucking...
I don't know why he was...
He went in!
I don't know why he fucking walked in there.
Why was he aggressing?
There's no...
There's no way.
Maybe like... maybe it's just hopeless.
Maybe...
Maybe it's just hopeless.
Alright.
This is actually crazy.
This is actually...
I messaged like two people but they are all like busy.
Oh my god.
I even messaged like non-stop.
Streamers and they're like...
They're like, sorry, we can't play right now.
Oh my god.
I'm letting my anger out on DPS.
More ice cream.
What the fuck?
Fuck off!
Okay, fuck this.
I'm angry.
No, fuck this.
I'm...
I'm gonna do something else.
Alright.
Let's see.
Alright, here we go.
Are you serious?!
Alright.
No, I was actually gonna play this character.
For full angry.
That's right.
Alright.
Full angry time.
Now I'm real angy angy.
Oh, I did not anticipate the range for that.
Now I'm full angry.
Oh, this Hanzo does not know.
You think I don't see you?
Oh my goodness.
I'm full mad.
That's so cute, right?
Alright.
I feel a bit better.
I feel a bit better ruining other people's days.
There it is.
I feel... I feel so much better ruining other people's days by playing D.Va on deathmatch.
This is it.
This is the strat.
The fucking strat.
The fucking Juno strat.
This is it.
Every time we go Juno and then we swap.
There's no way this...
This Mercy insta-picked Mercy so there's no way Juno strats the top 500.
Good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't think I've ever been this unlucky in Overwatch before.
The last couple of times through Overwatch, we were doing okay.
Things were a-okay.
This has been the most unlucky Overwatch session I've ever had.
Yeah, it has literally been the rank of all time.
Woo!
Oh shit.
Whoop.
Oh, definitely not straight out.
Oh, what?!
There's a Cassie behind us?!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I did not see that.
That's fine.
Now I know.
I mean, it doesn't matter, but like, now I know.
Like, it doesn't fucking matter.
Alright.
No, it's not time to swap.
It's not time to swap.
We can make it work.
If those other Junos never swap, why should I swap?
There's no need to swap, guys.
Okay, maybe I should swap.
Haha, maybe.
Maybe.
No, there's no need to swap.
I'm not the problem.
There's no need to swap.
That's fine.
We're fine.
We're so f- Wait, you can reflect that?!
Oh, I mean, it makes sense.
I'm not the problem.
I don't need to swap.
Why should I swap?
Oh, shit!
He smacked me!
Okay.
That's fine.
I'm still not the problem.
There's no way.
I'm not the problem here.
Alright, nice.
I'm trying to figure out how to, like, get to places faster.
Oh, shit.
What?
Okay.
There we go.
That's f-ing right.
That's f-ing right!
I told you!
I'm not the problem!
If they don't swap, why should I swap?
If they get to enjoy a full game of Juno, I should be able to enjoy a full game of Juno.
I should be allowed to enjoy Juno hours!
I'm not the problem!
I'm not the reason here.
Okay, Mercy, please.
Okay, never mind.
I saw them, I saw the Mercy fly away.
Okay, maybe I'm gonna go.
Maybe it's non-true.
No hours now.
Maybe they're right.
It's fine.
I'm here now.
That's fine.
Pick up the orb.
It's like Noverwild never changed.
Wings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm not the problem.
I'm swapping not because I think Juno's a bad character.
That's not why I'm swapping, guys.
I have other reasons why I would swap, guys.
It's not because I think Juno's a bad character.
It's because I think Juno is not a good character.
That's not it.
Alright, we go back.
Guys!
Woah!
Shit!
Okay.
Alright, I guess I'll fight here.
That's a little awkward.
Not gonna lie.
It's okay.
We got almost 90.
That's...
That's fine.
I have ult for this.
Alright.
Oh!
Oh, there's a little mini speed boost.
I swapped off Juno not because she was a problem.
Guys, I need you guys to know that.
It was...
It's just I needed to get there faster.
So, like, I had to swap.
You know?
Like, I had to swap because I had to...
I had to get to the destination.
That's fucking right.
Juno could have done this.
Done exactly this.
Okay, guys.
Juno...
Juno could have also...
I could have easily done this on Juno too, guys.
I just want you to know.
Alright.
We're fine.
Okay, attack.
All I'm saying is that we're doing it.
We're fucking doing it.
Winning because of Juno dip because they have Juno.
Damn.
That must suck.
Imagine having Juno.
Couldn't be me.
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Is our Winston okay over there?
I don't think our Winston's gonna live.
Oh, wait.
He did.
Alright.
Oh!
Shit!
That was scary.
Bro.
That was a little scary.
I might be dead though.
That's fine.
I'm still on point.
It's fine.
I'm still here.
Alright.
See?
We're doing okay.
I'm pretty sure that Winston has...
Oh no.
It's okay.
We didn't need him.
Please.
I beg of you.
Please don't.
I see you.
PISTOLING!
MERCY!
Holy shit!
I literally saw the Mercy pistoling.
Holy fuck.
I was not happy.
Don't make me!
I will use this!
I will...
Oh god.
Please, Mercy.
Alright.
I did what I could.
Guys, I think the Juno strat actually worked.
That's like the most...
Guys, I think...
I think it's the Juno strat.
I think it's the...
Guys, I figured it out.
Guys...
We figured out this strat.
We actually figured out this strat.
I just need to pick Juno.
Oh my god.
Guys, this is the Juno strat.
Hoping the opponent has Juno.
It's all I have to do is I pick Juno.
So my team, my other support can't play Juno.
And then when I do that, I swap off Juno.
Like, that's all I have to do.
Literally, the two games I won was because I made sure my other support could not play Juno.
It just works.
That is literally our saving grace right now.
We just always happen to have...
I mean, I'm fucking terrible at Juno.
Even I admit I don't know what I'm fucking doing when it comes to Juno.
Jesus Christ, that's fucked up.
No, that's the streamer mode name.
The Juno reverse card.
Rusty, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
As long as my team doesn't play Juno, like, we can act it.
There's hope.
There's actual hope.
Oh, fuck.
That's good.
I don't trust anybody on Juno.
Like, legitimately, I don't trust anybody on Juno right now.
I feel like every time
I see him, I'm like, what the fuck are you gonna do?
Freeze me?
Oh, shit.
Wait, that works?
Oh my god, he did.
What the fuck, he did freeze me.
I was joking.
I didn't realize that hurt.
That hits me all the way up there.
That was just fucking around.
You fucker!
I will kill...
I'll kill this meme.
It's the last thing I do.
No, you're not the meme.
Where are you?
No!
Alright, guys, I'm fine.
Where's Juno?
Where the fuck is this Juno?
Okay.
We figured it out.
We know...
We know the meta.
I guess, like, we need to figure out how to fucking walk around.
Yippee!
Okay, can I, like, go up?
No, okay.
I don't really like the controls of the glide.
The anti-Juno strat, yeah.
Alright.
She's cute!
Fucking hell, I hate her.
I hate her so much.
Alright.
This is my meta.
I insta-locked Juno so nobody can play Juno and then we, like, we have a game.
Okay, I can't save that.
Like, I...
I don't know what to do with that.
Okay.
Okay!
We...
did all we could.
We actually did all.
I think it's time where I pick a different character the moment I die.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Please, get one.
That's all I...
I just want one kill.
I just...
Please.
Please, he's so low.
Oh my god, I'm just healing the tank!
Nice.
Jesus Christ.
I almost have...
Nice!
That's fucking right!
Okay, he should be dead.
Thank god.
Oh, thank god!
I will fucking fly!
Oh!
This is it!
I knew it!
I fucking knew it!
Can we, like, make sure he's not there?
Alright.
Go, tank, go!
Alright, that did nothing.
Feels like...
Feels like I contributed...
What the fuck?
Okay, that was clutch.
Alright, here we go.
Why didn't I discover this meta sooner?
Why didn't...
Oh my god.
Why didn't I discover this meta?
I can't believe it.
Okay...
Alright, that's our grid.
I mean, I could swap, but like...
I'm not the problem.
Like...
We could swap, but like...
I don't think I'm the problem.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Oh, he's so low!
Oh, god.
I'm trying my best.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I'm fucking flying.
They have mail.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Okay, thank god.
It's fine.
We're fine.
It's not mail, though.
I'm a little worried with the mail.
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Yeah, this guy knows what he's doing.
Which is nice.
Alright.
I told you I'm not the problem.
I told you guys.
I know what I'm doing.
Okay.
Okay, they have...
Oh, no.
Does that hit me?
Where is our orbit?
I was gonna say...
Where is it?
I hate her ult.
Oh, wait.
She lives?
How?
Go get him, Bob!
Get in there.
Speed!
Oh, god.
I threw.
I'm so sorry.
I did not mean to do that.
I told you guys.
I'm so good at Juno.
It's like a damage boost.
But like...
Feels useless.
Okay.
We're fine.
Yes, I do.
Goodbye.
That was such a good pull.
Holy shit.
Oh, guys.
I'm a little...
Nice.
It's just the ride.
Hey.
Nice.
Easy.
Hey, what about me?
I did stuff.
I...
What is everyone talking about the...
What about me?
I kept people alive.
I literally picked...
If I didn't pick Juno, he would not pick Life Weaver.
Guys.
If I didn't...
Guys, you gotta congratulate me for picking Juno.
Because me picking Juno allows him to play Life Weaver.
If I wasn't here, we wouldn't have gotten this Life Weaver.
You're doing great.
Sweet.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I literally made it so that he had to play Life Weaver, guys.
You're welcome.
Awesome job, team.
And Juno too, I guess.
Rusty, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nobody can appreciate my genius.
My meta-crafting.
Nobody...
Nobody knows the things I go through until I put on the mask.
You want my clothes?
Sorry, guys.
What in the hell they talk?
Alright.
You're fucking welcome.
Oh, he ate it!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, okay.
What the fuck?
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god, that was weird.
Please!
Somebody kill him!
Nice.
We did it.
We killed him.
He's like one!
See?
Look at that!
Sorry.
My aimbot was acting up there.
I like how I can say that and know you guys don't believe me because I lost four games in a row.
They're like, sure.
Aimbot.
I hit
him?
Oh, I did.
There we go.
Does that do anything?
Why doesn't it do anything?
I swear the AWP does nothing!
We got the victory.
Okay.
I guess.
Our poor Widow.
Oh, the Widow's still alive.
Good for him.
You got it?
No!
The awp!
He's so low!
What the fuck?
They're running!
They're literally running the same comp!
Somebody please kill him.
Shoot him in the back.
Please.
Holy fuck.
I fly.
I stopped flying.
Flying was a mistake.
Oh no.
I feel like every time I ult, it does nothing.
I'm not happy about her ult at all.
That's funny.
That was a good pull.
That was actually a really good pull there.
That's a really funny pull.
I think I won't do it too!
That's fucking right!
Vector vs Vector!
We're despicable being this shit!
Fuck.
Look at that.
Both Juno did nothing.
Actually...
That's fine.
Both Juno...
contributed nothing.
Guys, I think it's time...
I swapped off Juno.
I didn't think it...
Wait, unless...
I'm fucking gonna...
Oh shit!
I fucked up.
I fucked up and I used the wrong ability.
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right!
Get staggered!
Goodbye!
I won't make sense!
He's fine.
He's so fine.
Alright.
I almost killed him too!
Oh, that was a good roll.
Oh god, no.
Oh no.
Guys, why didn't I swap off Juno when I had the chance?
Why did...
Why did I swap off Juno when I had the chance?
He's a cunning failsafe.
I forgot the second part of the strat.
Guys, there's a second part of the strat and it requires me to swap off Juno.
Oh, no.
Guys, it's fine.
If I die here, please...
Why...?
No!
I want to swap off Juno.
No, I don't have time to swap off Juno!
No!
I'm part of the problem now!
I didn't do the second part of the strat!
I got too cocky!
They have Mei on!
Oh god.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh god!
Oh my god!
Okay, they can still touch.
Please just zap!
Just zap her!
Yes!
I'm not the problem!
We figured it out!
I told you guys!
If they can have fun with Juno, I can have fun with Juno!
I knew I wasn't the problem!
GG Life Weaver.
I'm looking up 6k damage!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
I fucking knew it!
I knew it!
I just needed to commit!
Her ult still fucking sucks!
But like, I fucking knew it!
Oh my god, her ult is still dog shit.
I hate her ult.
They say they healed Life Weaver.
I have the same amount of heals as him!
And I have 6k more damage than the Life Weaver!
I even think it was super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's go, Life Weaver!
Guys.
Maybe I am the best Juno kit player in the world.
Maybe...
Maybe I can just play Juno the entire time.
Alright.
I saved the Life Weaver's butt too, guys!
Not just him!
Saving my life!
Weee!
Okay.
Alright, we're fine.
Okay, we might not be fine.
Guys, we might not be fine because...
We might not be fine.
We might not be as fine as I thought we were.
We might not be as fine as I thought I was.
Wait, we got point?
Wait, I'm a fucking amazing Juno player!
Wait, I'm her!
Holy shit!
Wait!
I might just be like a prodigy Juno!
Alright, it's time to use the most fucking useless hull in the world.
That's fucking right.
What you gonna do?
Go fast!
This was the issue.
I should have 100% be playing Juno this entire time.
I was the Juno guy.
Alright, that's fine.
He has ult, by the way.
Yep, I...
Yep.
Look at them!
They purposely targeted me because I'm her!
That was one... oh shit!
That was 100% on purpose.
I mean...
I fucking knew it.
They 100% focused me because I was just that good, guys.
I was just that good.
Why didn't I play Juno sooner?
Chat!
No!
They just WP'd into us!
Please!
We lost the first seed!
I couldn't do anything about it!
Alright...
No!
I don't need a swap!
I don't need a swap, guys.
I'm her.
You don't understand.
I'm literally the Juno player.
Okay...
You guys should swap, maybe.
Okay, now I'm a little concerned.
What the fuck?!
There's a soldier behind us?!
Hey, uh, Juno, can you please kill me?
Now definitely won't heal her.
If you're not gonna heal me, I'm not gonna heal you.
Okay, sure.
Let's do it.
Bro, if you think I'm not that spiteful, I actually will be.
Bro, that's like things you say to people to make sure they definitely won't heal.
Like, why would I heal you now for being such a spiteful bitch?
Little does she know, I'm also as equally spiteful.
Holy shit!
Little does she know, now I definitely won't heal her.
That's my OG.
All I'm saying is that she could have said it much more politely.
She could have 100% said that much more politely.
Juno does not heal.
Juno now DPS.
Yes.
She messes around Juno.
She would be like, oh hey Juno, can you heal me?
And I'll be like, okay.
I literally out-healed her too.
Aww, that's unlucky.
Ooh, that's very unlucky.
No, that was an accident!
Alright, I didn't mean to heal her there.
Alright, let's go.
Ooh, that's a lot.
Alright.
I need the speed there.
Holy shit.
Just gonna give them heals first.
So then I can...
Woo!
Oh my god, you already got rocket barrage?
Jesus!
Oh shit!
I did not even realize they had a Bastion!
I didn't even notice!
I didn't even notice the Bastion existed!
I've not seen...
I've not seen them at all!
Okay.
Okay, Juno's not working now.
Oh, he definitely has ult.
It would be very unfortunate if...
If she gets killed there.
Oh, where are we going?
Where the fuck are we going?
Alright.
It's fine.
I got you!
Okay, I don't got you anymore.
Okay, I definitely don't got you anymore.
Okay, it's time to play Kiriko.
Actually...
Yeah, no Kiriko.
Alright.
Wait.
Oh!
That's unlucky.
Let me balance you out!
Alright,
here we go.
Does he have ult?
I can't tell.
I don't remember if he used it or not.
Alright, I guess I'll do this.
God, this is definitely not enough heals.
Holy shit.
Kiriko does not do enough.
Oh my god.
I had to do this.
Oh nice.
Oh that's awkward.
Oh we got a point.
Alright, you go this way, I'll go this way.
You go... Alright.
Hello.
Oh my god.
Wait, does he have refraud?
Oh, wait, wait, unless!
Unless!
Wait!
Oh no, it's not possible.
No, it's not possible.
No, it's definitely not.
There's not enough heals for this.
Unless?!
Unless!!!
Here we go.
Alright.
It's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, thank god!
No!
We won!
Wait, no, we didn't.
Wait, we're 44.
Never mind.
Oh, thank god.
I was gonna say, I wanna play one more round.
I was saying, I really actually wanna play one more round of this.
There's definitely not enough heals.
Not gonna lie.
We have not enough heals for this.
No, there's... yeah, we're fucked.
It's time.
Yes!
Another fight!
We get another round!
Let's fucking go!
You know the best part?
She's gonna avoid me, so I don't have to waste my void slots.
That's the best part.
I know she's gonna avoid me, so I don't have to worry about it.
The holy shit!
She's so passive-aggressive!
This is why...
I don't understand why people...
Bro, I was playing the same game.
This is why, like, literally, I don't care.
They think I care that much about winning.
Be more polite.
Legitimately.
Be...
If we lose, by the way, it's on Kiri.
Holy shit!
Caught live!
The most...
Why is it always Mercy players that are so passive-aggressive?
I don't understand.
At least I'm not passive-aggressive to people on chat.
Like, I'm just doing it for stream.
Like...
I don't understand why.
Like, I... like, I don't understand why they're always so passive-aggressive.
I will find the key.
Be nourished.
Really, all they have to do is just be nice about it.
But she came in, like, fucking shooting right away.
I love that she'll avoid me, though.
Holy shit.
I'm so happy.
I don't have to waste my avoid slot.
Okay.
Oh...
Come back, come back, Wind Thorn!
Nice.
Woo!
Okay.
Nice.
She has to heal me now!
That's the best part!
Now you have to heal me!
It's your all!
That's so cute, right?
You can't not heal me now, bitch!
Holy shit.
I still have more heal center!
Thanks for the free heals.
That's fucking crazy.
How do I still have more heals?
Holy shit.
Your fucking pocket.
Goodbye.
OH SHE HEALED ME!
YOU STILL HEALED ME!
BITCH!
THIS IS WHY I WIN!
SO BADLY!
I DIDN'T HEAL YOU A SINGLE TIME!
CAUSE I DIDN'T CARE!
Oh fuck, I healed her.
That was on instinct too.
That was my first heal.
My first heal of the day, by the way.
Oh my god.
That was actually the very first heal I did to her, too.
Which I thought was funny.
Alright.
Oh shit, that's my bear.
Oh, that's embarrassing for her.
Oh no, that's embarrassing for us.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
Oh my god, I died so fast.
She actually healed me.
Okay.
Nice.
We did it.
I'm okay with losing this.
Like...
How do people feel?
Alright.
Because that's an avoid slot I don't have to worry about.
Okay.
Holy shit.
This guy...
They're duo'd.
She literally...
All she does is pocket him.
Literally...
All...
Damage boost pocket.
They don't...
She doesn't...
The thing is, I haven't seen her...
Oh, there it is.
I was gonna say it.
I felt like I haven't seen her damage boost the fucking Reaper.
Oh, she cocked the orb.
Alright, goodbye.
Save your fucking pocket!
Please, Cassidy.
I fucking...
Cassidy, I'm literally leaving you now.
Oh my god.
And I still have more heals.
And I
still did Betty.
I...
Holy shit.
I didn't...
I only healed her one time in that entire game.
I healed...
Ever since she got so toxic at me.
I healed her one time.
And she healed me.
She won me.
And I had...
I did that win more than me.
I did not care.
Like.
You see this?
If we lose by the way, it's on Kiri.
Smile.
Holy fuck.
Oh, my god.
Oh.
Oh, no, he's talking about the enemy Mora.
I'm sorry, buddy.
I'm sorry.
She didn't follow through!
I followed through!
The only reason she got healed was because she caught my orb.
I was throwing a heal orb.
Holy shit.
I can literally play the same game.
She thinks I care about my emo today.
Oh my god.
That's satisfying to watch.
She thought she could outspite Doki.
What a fool.
What a fucking fool.
Thank you for the super chat, Johnny.
Thank you, thank you.
The thing is, the thing is, like, she could have been a lot nicer about asking for heals.
I don't know.
I didn't even realize she needed heals.
Because, like, I didn't even notice until she was like, um, can you, like, heal me?
Do you know?
Or like, I won't heal you if you don't.
And I'm like, what?
I was just like, what?
Why are you so passive aggressive?
Yeah, I'd be like, hey, can you, like, heal?
Or can you peel for me?
And I'll be like, okay.
No, thank you for telling me.
Yeah.
She could have just, like, fucking asked nicely.
Oh my god.
I don't understand.
They're always so passive aggressive, too.
I have so many, like...
It's either tank players or...
It's either, like...
Uh, no.
Actually, no.
It's, like, specific players.
Rein players?
Rein?
Rein players can be passive aggressive, too.
And then, um...
And then, like, uh, Widow players.
Uh...
And then there's also...
But then Mercy players for support.
You know, thank you for the five gift ships.
Thank you.
Yay!
No, there's some...
Passive aggressive DPS players.
Uh...
Genji...
Genji and Widows.
They're super passive aggressive.
I think it's because, like...
I only think it's, like, heroes that get...
You know who are the chillest people?
Torb one tricks and Symmetra one tricks.
There...
Torb and Symmetra one tricks are so chill.
They're so chill.
Because they always have to experience so much hate that they just don't care.
They literally don't care.
They're so chill because they're like, well, I'm already the problem, so...
They're just like, I know I'm the problem, so like, I don't care.
Holy fuck.
That was my favorite game, honestly.
That was literally my favorite game of today.
Oh my god, this bitch.
I wish I played against her.
That's all I wanted.
Goddamn.
Alright.
That would have been so funny.
Woo!
Whee!
Yeah, but when you avoid me, there's a chance you get in my... you get on the opposite team.
That's why I was hoping... because I knew she was 100% avoiding me.
Like, I knew... I knew she 100% already wasted her avoid slots on me.
So that means I can...
Oh, that's an arrow right there.
That's an arrow right there.
Yo!
Boom.
Oh, break.
That's the first break I saw today.
Wait.
I hear a...
Yep, there it...
There he is.
Oh, he's so low!
Get gripped.
It was so low!
Oh, shit.
Okay, goodbye.
Guess no grippers for you.
Oh, shit.
My bad.
Slowly float away.
No!
I was like...
Slowly float away?
I was just like...
Yay.
Nobody's gonna kill me, right?
Bye.
Okay.
Okay, I thought the... I thought I would get more...
Did I go through this?
I did.
Okay.
Oh, he's one!
That's fucking right.
What?!
Oh
fuck!
Oh no!
I hope I don't get a noise complaint!
Oh, I fucked up!
For hours, I never closed my door!
Oh
no!
No, my glass door!
Oh no!
The door was never closed!
Oh, I'm sorry if I get a noise complaint.
Oh, fuck.
Goodbye.
You were so dead.
Oh, that is awkward.
That is actually so awkward.
Woo!
Goodbye.
Oh, shit!
Okay, now I'm here, I guess.
This ends now.
Grip.
I am!
Don't worry!
Sending the nuke!
Oh, okay, I wasted that.
I... I...
Whoops.
It's not a waste if that fucking...
If this ult means nothing.
It's never a waste.
Because this ult does nothing.
Whoops.
Alright, nice.
Alright, we're fine.
We're not fine.
Fly through it!
He's so low!
I'm learning how to player!
It's not a waste.
It's a bad ult anyway, so it's not a waste.
Exactly.
Alright.
Lightspeed.
Okay, we're doing pretty good.
Not gonna lie.
Okay.
Like, I'm doing enough healings, I think.
I'll just do that for now.
Get healed.
What do you mean throwing?
How am I throwing?
I'm doing my job.
As a healer.
How?
Oh!
Goodbye.
There's no way.
Sorry Hanzo, I had to fucking go.
Alright.
Okay.
I...
Jesus!
He really wanted to kill me.
Holy shit.
Okay.
After this ult, I'll swap off Juno.
Guys, after this ult, I swear to God, I'll swap off Juno.
Like, this time, for real.
Like, I'm not fucking...
I'm not joking this time.
It's orbit time.
Oh, he hit the car!
He hit the car!
Holy shit!
He actually hit the car!
He couldn't hit me!
That's funny.
That's pretty funny.
Oh, this might be where I die.
Life did not protect me.
Oh, he did it!
Wait, that means I can stay on Juno!
Oh my god!
I think I'm not the problem.
So I can stay on Juno.
I'm not the problem.
I can't believe it.
When we finally figured out the strat, life just got so much easier.
It really did.
I want to add that Mercy as a friend.
So then I can purposely...
I can talk to her and be like, Hey!
And smile.
Alright.
You're so evil!
This Mercy...
She lives rent-free in my head ever since.
I hope I live rent-free in her head as much as she lives rent-free in my head.
I never forget.
That's the thing.
Alright.
Sniper, okay.
Jesus!
I just realized how much fucking ammo I have.
Whoa!
Are we still here?
Alright.
There's so much ammo for healing though.
Not gonna lie.
Just gonna do that for now.
While I reload.
Oh!
That's unfortunate!
Back up if you need to!
It's fine.
We're okay.
Oh!
This is not good for me.
Woo!
Alright!
Let's go!
Oh!
Let's not go.
Let's go!
Oh!
It's fine.
They knew I was the problem!
What?
Did chat break?
Did it?
Let's go!
Okay.
It's alright.
They know.
The thing that...
What I like is there's no falloff too.
There's no falloff damage...
Fall off for Juno.
Yeah!
Destroy him!
Oh shit!
I'm okay.
Everything is fine.
Okay!
Oh my god!
Someone please!
I'm hurt!
I'm actually hurt!
Holy fuck!
I'm so good!
I'm so good at judo!
I'm so scared.
Alright.
I still think she's a fucking terrible character.
I don't think she's actually that good.
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh god, please Ashe.
No!
You walked back!
And she didn't walk backwards!
Holy shit!
That's so unlucky!
She walked backwards!
That's unlucky.
I don't think we can get there.
Yeah, we're not getting there.
No,
do you have healing with gun?
Bro, what?
Ana has like sniper gun.
I think they all heal.
All of them heal with gun.
Almost.
Bap's a gun!
Don't worry.
We're going in.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Don't worry, we're going in.
Oh shit!
Force trance!
Oh, he didn't want to force trance.
Oh shit!
No!
I got...
She's so low!
Fucking what?!
Okay.
Don't worry, we're fine.
Alright, we're fine.
What the fuck?!
No way!
He's camping me!
That's fucked.
That's actually fucked.
Holy shit.
That's fine.
That's not fine.
It was not fine, actually.
That's it.
It ended up not being as fine.
Are you fucking... Are you kidding me?
Are you kidding me?!
I can't be her anymore!
I...
No,
I can't be her.
That's not fair.
But I wanna be her.
I can't be her.
No!
I told you, they knew I was the problem.
What the fuck?!
That's just embarrassing.
Sad.
Jesus Christ.
Holy shit.
What a fucking play.
That's actually a crazy fucking...
That's fucked.
That's so fucked.
Guys, all I'm saying is that...
They targeted me.
She's still alive!
Okay.
That's it.
How the fuck?
Oh, shit.
I mean, that's fine.
No, that is not fine.
It stopped being fine.
It stopped being... Never mind.
Guys, it... It stopped being fine, guys.
Yay!
I perfected the Juno strat.
I can't... You know what?
Do you think we could get to med?
I...
I can't believe it.
I can't!
No, guys.
It's actually so dumb.
Oh, my God.
Oh,
I can't believe...
Oh, my God.
I couldn't even master it.
I could have placed in Masters if I... if I like just went with it.
We could... oh my god, we could have been in Masters if I just picked Juno.
If I... if I just picked Juno.
The fact that I like... the fact that I was just...
The fact that I was just, you know...
I don't know if you guys know this, but I was actually fucking around, like...
I didn't expect that strat to actually work, you know?
To be like... it was just a he-he-ha-ha stream moment.
Where it's like, you know...
And it worked.
It can't believe it actually worked.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's the silly ideas!
It really is!
It's... it's the fucking silly ideas.
Alright, I'll do LG.
This will be my LG.
I wanna know...
Uh...
Maybe... I wanna know.
I wanna know if... if it'll work after placements.
I made it work.
I actually... I actually made it work.
I can't believe we had the worst start in our rank... in our... in our rank queues.
And everything just worked out.
Everything just worked out in the end.
I mean... five... that... you know, I thought... you know...
We're gonna have more than five.
But like... I feel... the VOD watchers are gonna be like...
Oh man...
It's gonna go be bad, isn't it?
But no...
There's always hope.
And there's always a light at the end of the tunnel.
And that is why I love Overwatch.
Like... I... this is why I stayed with Overwatch for this long.
It's a great game.
And like... eventually... eventually they start changing.
And...
Eventually things will work out in the end.
And... this is why... this is why I love playing Overwatch.
And...
And I think it's definitely one of the best CO shooters out there.
And... and it gave me lots of happiness.
You know?
It's tough love.
At first it tried... it tried to give me like...
All the bad matches.
But it's tough... it was testing me.
Guys, you don't understand.
Overwatch was literally... he... he was testing me.
Testing me... my commitment to him.
And like... I knew if I stayed long enough...
There was light at the end of the tunnel.
And that... and that he was gonna change.
And he did!
He did... he changed.
Guys, you don't understand.
You guys don't understand.
Alright...
No!
It's over.
I hesitated.
I did it!
It's already over!
I didn't insta-lock!
It's over.
The hesitation.
I was like leaning back on my chair relaxing and was like I was just relaxing but leaning back and then leaning back and then I was like hehe and they picked Juno.
They picked Juno.
It's over.
It's already so over.
There's only one person that can play.
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Alright.
Oh shit!
Go Genji!
Go!
Oh.
Bye Genji.
Bye.
Please don't die.
No!
He's gonna be mega staggered!
JK.
Oh fuck.
Nevermind.
I'm not playing Ana against this fucking hell.
I hate playing Ana against shields.
I'm so used to playing Juno.
I don't know how to play Ana anymore.
I actually don't know how to play the game anymore.
Juno's mobility is actually insane though.
I'll admit.
Like I was not expecting how insane Juno's mobility is.
She makes you feel like a butterfly.
No!
She actually makes you feel like a butterfly.
Juno!
Why didn't you shoot me Juno?
Adam!
I love that video.
I hate him.
You guys know that video?
The duck video?
That's how I feel when I yell at Juno.
It's okay.
It's not okay.
Is this how the Mercy felt playing with me?
Is this how she felt?
Nope.
I don't deserve that.
No,
I'm a good person.
I haven't been passive aggressive yet.
Oh shit.
Second use assault.
Oh wow, what is he going to do?
Shoot us?
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh shit!
Alright.
Nice.
Guys, I'm going to get my first ult soon guys.
This is it.
Guys.
I guess I'm going to get my first ult.
Guys, it's going to be so cool.
It's going to be so fun.
Wow!
Guys, this is it.
The retake.
Guys, I'm going to get my first ult right here guys.
This is it.
It's going to be so sick.
My one and only ult.
It's going to be so fucking sick guys.
You don't understand.
Oh no, he's staggered.
That's bad.
This is it.
Right here.
Whoa!
It's still here.
I told you.
I told you it's going to be so sick.
It doesn't matter.
It took me one entire game to build all of it.
It was a sick ass ult though.
It was a sick ult.
It worked out.
The ult was so fucking sick.
Alright.
I'm going to go Q.
I'll find my own path.
It might have taken me an entire game.
But like...
But like I ulted when it mattered the most.
The wicked play.
Yay!
The game...
Hey!
We won!
That one round.
We won that one round.
That's all that matters.
Jesus Christ.
Why is that bugging out?
Juno.
Don't die.
Oh.
I hope I don't die.
God.
My heal output is so weak.
I'm helping.
Is he going to Wraith?
Whoa.
Shit.
Sorry bro.
Sucks to be you.
I guess.
Wait.
Is that her?
My Juno?
Or their Juno?
Juno.
No.
That was our Juno.
That was enemy Juno.
Nice staggered.
Alright.
Oh.
Nah.
I'm not going to waste cleanse here.
I feel like...
Did I nerf Kiriko's heals?
She feels so weak.
Not going to lie.
This feels weak in general.
No?
Okay.
I might be just used to...
other healers.
Must not be using Juno enough then.
Not Juno.
Kiriko.
Sorry.
I meant Kiriko.
Did they nerf Kiriko's heals?
That's what I mean.
Sorry.
I have Juno brain rot right now.
Everything is a Juno to me.
I actually have Juno brain rot.
Nice.
Kiriko's...
Kiriko's heals feel so fucking weak.
Not going to lie.
But I don't know if it's because I've been playing Juno and other... and Ana for too long.
That every other character feels...
That her heals feel weak.
She's so...
Ha!
Bitch!
That's what you get.
Oh!
Goodbye!
No!
My cockiness has betrayed me yet again!
It's okay.
We have ult.
It's fine.
I couldn't even cleanse.
It's okay.
We have...
We have the ult that matters.
When the fuck did we Juno ulted?
Holy shit.
I don't even remember that.
Alright.
Here we go.
You go do your thing.
Because I know...
Did we just run away from it?
That's awkward.
I liked how...
Um...
Oh, no.
Wait.
Everybody died?
How?
How the fuck did everybody die?
What the fuck?
Bro, I don't have enough heals for this.
Oh!
What do you mean?
How did you all die?
No!
I got... No, dude.
It's not a result.
Because I fucking cleansed it.
That's why I was so confused.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Maybe worry a little bit.
Oh, no.
I'm trying my best to keep you up.
There's not a lot of heals going in, but I'm doing my best.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's awkward.
Oh, that's...
That's very awkward.
Guys, I think it's just a Juno diff.
If I was on Juno, this game would be so different.
Yeah, it works on the result.
I just need to use it at the right time.
Like, I need to use it when he like, uh, throws his spear down.
Oh, god.
I...
Oh.
That's awkward.
That's very awkward.
That's okay, Gengu!
Keep slicing and dicing!
Just slice and dice!
No, I couldn't go in!
Tracer, this is it!
This is your time to shine!
If I was on Juno, this would have been easier.
That's all I'm gonna say.
Alright, guys.
I know what to do.
Now nobody will die.
The Juno strat was legit.
I would play Juno if I could!
If I could!
Oh my god, I can't believe the Juno strat was the reason why I was winning.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it really was.
That's so fucked.
That's actually so fucked.
Who would have thought?
Oh, that's the flower.
Alright.
Okay.
Bye.
It's fine.
If nobody dies, we'll be fine.
I keep thinking shift is not that.
I keep...
I keep using the shift thinking it's my jump, but it's not.
No, Gengar!
Oh god.
Okay.
How do I grip?
If you don't look at me!
Oh shit.
Hello.
Goodbye.
Get in!
It's tree time!
Tree!
Now I'm that life weaver.
There we go.
It's fine.
I treed.
Oh god, Genji, please.
Not again.
Genji, please.
I don't know how to grip if you're all the way there.
Oh, thanks for the...
I really appreciate that.
Oh no.
Wait, I gave myself that.
Oh, I thought that was the enemy life weaver.
When did the fuck...
When did I threw the petal?
I was like, whoa, thanks life weaver.
I'm the life weaver.
I literally thought...
I thought the enemy...
I was like, where did that petal came from?
I don't know, but I was so surprised.
I was legitimately like, huh, where did that petal come from?
Oh shit.
It's orbit time.
What?
Please.
Please, somebody shoot me.
Where are the shots?
Yes, a medal to me.
Get gripped.
Oh, wrong grip.
Oh, he has...
Oh shit.
Oh shit, please.
Please.
Get me out of here.
I swear to god.
Holy fuck.
There was no fucking...
There was...
Oh, I see nine.
Oh my god.
Maybe I'm just really good at life weaver as well.
That's it.
Maybe I'm just...
Wait, let's do one more.
Let's do...
We might... guys, guys, we might be able... guys, we might be able to get to masters, guys.
That's me.
Maybe I could get to masters, guys.
Heh, heh, heh.
Guys, guys.
I'm okay.
Hehehehehe.
Heh, heh, heh, heh.
Heh, heh, heh.
For real, for real.
I could technically get to masters in 2 or 3 games.
In two to three games, I can technically get to Masters.
If I just win two to three games straight.
No,
no.
It'll be different.
Guys, it'll be so different.
You don't understand.
We found out what was the... We found out the key.
We found the key.
Anta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There's no red flags.
It's all green flags, guys.
You don't understand.
Overwatch was right about you guys.
I wish there were no green flags.
Toki, please.
I can't find a green flag.
So have some lettuce.
Excuse me.
Me?
You told me you guys were trying to take me away from Overwatch.
Green flags and Toki is colorblind.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay.
Everything will be fine.
We'll stop when we lose.
Chat.
We're gonna stop when we lose.
Alright, suit yourself.
Guys, we're gonna stop when we lose, guys.
Guys, we'll stop when we lose, guys.
And if we keep winning, well, we just keep winning.
Toki, it's not too late.
Just say the word and we'll get you out of here.
Tia, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Get me out of what?
I'm in a very loving relationship with Overwatch.
He's changed, guys.
You don't understand.
We've been winning.
Like, yeah, it was rough at the beginning.
But like, it got better.
It got better.
It got so much better.
It got so...
I love Overwatch.
We lost.
Guys, I...
Guys, I love Overwatch.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it, though.
Ever since I went crazy with the Juno strat.
Things are looking up.
Things really are looking up for me.
They always say that, but they're not.
No, it's fine.
Guys, it's fine.
Everything is fine.
The keyword is crazy.
Crazy.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna auto-lock.
We're gonna auto-lock.
Guys, I figured it out.
I just...
All I have to do...
Is...
All we need to do...
Is basically...
We play either Life Weaver...
Life Weaver...
Or Juno.
If we can't get Juno, we get Life Weaver.
Are you...
Okay.
We start...
This might be...
I feel like this is a sign.
If that's...
There's a Rein and a D.Va running around.
I feel like this is a sign of...
This is a sign of...
Or like what this game...
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
It's not over yet.
It's not over yet, guys!
Alright.
This is it.
God, I love Overwatch.
I hope Overwatch is on for 10 more years.
Please Dokia, I want to sleep.
Alright, here we go.
Also, after replacing, I'm not going to play until like...
until like a week or two later.
So then everything will be stabilized.
Oh, I forgot to do this.
Oh my god, I forgot I played Juno.
It only took one game.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Everything is fine.
Okay, it's only because I haven't touched on...
I still haven't built the muscle memory for Juno yet.
Guys, I haven't built the muscle memory.
So the fact that I have to go back to Juno afterwards...
It's understandable.
It's understandable!
Oh god.
Alright.
I should be able to push in, right?
Woah.
Okay.
Woah!
Alright, we're staggered now.
We're... we're staggered.
Oh shit.
Hey, the Reaper is okay.
Oh, we're hella staggered now.
Oh, we are.
We are so staggered.
Don't worry, I got you.
Okay, we have the orbital.
Alright guys, I don't think Juno is the pick.
I think it's time to do plan...
the second plan of...
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Alright.
Please!
I was healing you!
I healed you so much!
Alright, Kiriko tap.
It's Kiriko tap.
I healed you so much.
Alright, it's time for the second plan.
Hahaha.
Bring it in.
What's that?
What the fuck?
Ohgah.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Guys, I think this is the last game now.
Guys.
I don't understand.
It's always been working.
WHAT HAPPENED?!
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE STRAIGHT?!
I don't understand.
He definitely has shatter, by the way.
He 100% has shatter.
There's no fucking way he does not have shatter.
Wait, what?
Why?
Okay.
Um, okay.
I'm gonna cap.
This is it.
Yippee!
Everything will be fine!
It's just like two to three, guys.
It's winnable.
Whoa!
Wait, where is that?
Alright.
I saved him.
Oh my god!
He is...yep.
Not saved.
Is this winnable still?
Alright.
Oh...
That poor man.
I'm trying my best to keep you alive, bro.
No!
He saw me!
Oh my god!
I thought he did not exist!
I think your DPS is better than our DPS.
Woo!
Guys, are you...you guys are...okay.
It's fine.
We don't need that point, guys.
This...it'll be different.
Oh my god.
It'll be different here!
See?
We got a pig!
It'll be so different!
Okay...
Hehehe!
Oh, we are trying so hard to keep you alive.
Oh, my gosh!
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
Oh, my gosh!
Okay...
This Kenji definitely has a...
That's fine!
We can grab it and get it back!
Haha!
We can get it back.
Overwatch wouldn't do this to me.
He has shatter.
Guys,
go in!
Go in, please!
Please go in!
Go into the point!
We don't have to care about him!
Why didn't we go to the point?
Okay.
That's fine.
The ride's coming back.
That's okay.
Guys, I think I hit Clash.
I think I still hit Clash.
Oh god.
Oh yeah.
Oh, it's over.
It's over.
I don't understand.
How did the strat stop working?
How did you die so fast?
You had nano!
Holy shit.
Guys.
I should have played Life Weaver.
I forgot the second part.
Just an unlucky game?
You're right.
I should go next.
Okay.
But, like, you're...
Guys.
You're right.
It was just unlucky.
The next game...
It'll be different.
We can't end it on a loss.
Chat?
Chat!
We can't end it on a loss!
Guys.
We...
Don't you know?
If you end on a loss...
Then, like...
Then, like, why would I want to be sad with losing?
It's true!
Guys.
Just...
Just think about it this way!
We gotta end on a win!
We gotta...
Just think about it!
Guys!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
Put something on real fast.
If you're gonna be this loser...
What are you talking about?
I don't know what you're talking about!
What do you mean?
Talulu?
I'm not Talulu!
What do you mean, Talulu?
Talulu!
What do you mean?
I'm perfectly fine...
Guys.
Guys, I'm perfectly fine.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm okay.
I'm okay...
I love Overwatch.
Overwatch has always been so nice to me.
I love...
I love Overwatch.
Overwatch will never hurt me.
Don't keep this as an intervention.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, Alan.
What intervention?
Why?
Overwatch has always been there for me.
Where have you guys been?
Where were you guys six years ago?
Overwatch was so nice to me.
It was there for me six years ago.
Alright, don't worry.
This is last game chat for real.
For real.
What do you mean?
If your loved ones have been affected by Overwatch 2, lend them an ear and a shoulder to lean on if they need it.
It's okay.
We can do this.
Guys, we can do this.
I believe.
This is it.
We're gonna win here.
We're gonna win here and then...
And then...
After that, we're gonna win.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I need like...
Let me...
Let me get rid of...
We'll be fine.
We'll be... We'll be so fine.
Guys...
We'll be so fine.
We'll be okay.
We'll be...
We're attacked so I don't have to worry.
That's the wrong way.
Oops.
Oh, there it is.
It was too busy.
I lost the instant.
We'll be okay.
Let's go team.
I'm gonna try to move my fight.
Oh shit, you're right.
Life Weaver.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Nice.
That's good.
What is this Mercy doing?
Okay.
There's a Reaper right here.
There's a Reaper right...
Wait, I can pick Juno!
Guys, I can pick Juno, guys.
Guys, you know what our Hammond needs?
Juno.
Alright, good job.
That's what our Hammond needs.
Pick up the red.
That's exactly what he needs.
Careful.
Jesus Christ.
Oh.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is he doing?
Holy shit.
Oh shit.
Guys, I told you.
I told you Overwatch will never...
will never disappoint me.
Oh no no.
Oh no.
I got Sombra now.
Wait, that's not fair.
You're not supposed to counterswap.
That is illegal.
Counterswap in my Overwatch game?
You're supposed to one trick one hero.
And that's it.
Keep pushing the payload.
Nice.
Jesus Christ.
Pardon.
Oh.
Oh, goodbye!
Yeah, Overwatch is there for me since the beginning.
Overwatch would never disappoint me if you said no one every.
right now Overwatch would never disappoint me in the next 10 minutes.
Oh shit.
What a piece of shit.
Get over here.
That's unlucky.
What the fuck?
I'm feeling deployed.
Monkey low.
Is monkey dead?
Woo, I did that.
Don't worry, I got you.
Oh, don't!
Okay.
That's awkward.
Oh my god.
Five minutes?
I told you!
Holy shit!
Oh my gosh, you'll never disappoint me!
We both panicked.
We both fucking panicked.
Me and the Zen both panicked there.
He panicked, I panicked, but it was the worst outcome.
Guys, we need to change!
Guys!
This was my job.
This is my job.
Hey, Miss.
Yay.
Good eye!
How about that?
Jump, jump, jump.
Jump!
Oh game!
Jesus!
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Alright,
this is it.
This is it.
Jump, jump, jump, jump!
Jump!
See?
I'm doing it.
What's he gonna do?
Jump at us?
Guys, I think he's gonna jump at us.
Guys, I think he wants to jump at us.
Don't worry Zenyatta!
I'll never let them do this to you!
Oh god.
I keep forgetting my E.
This is it.
I'm the Juno player.
Juno might be dogshit, but like, I'm her.
We can go.
I have no muscle memory for her yet though.
What the fuck?
What did he do?
Killed his ass in his spawn.
What the f- wait.
What the fuck?
Who's over here?
Yeah, who's the Mora?
What the fuck is going on?
Oh I can't jump high.
That's bullshit.
I'm like trying to figure out how high I can jump for this.
Okay.
Oh no!
No way.
Oh no.
This is bad.
This is bad now.
What do we do?
There's no TP highground.
Oh god.
We keep each other alive.
Don't worry, bro.
And we keep each other alive.
Oh shit, our Junkrat is really good.
We're so good.
This is a very goofy match.
We actually have a good Hammond player.
That's actually crazy.
We have a good Hammond.
Yeah, Stickman is really a Junkrat.
Alright.
It's fine.
Everything is a-okay.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Nobody took any damage!
Oh, spoke too soon.
Oh, whoa, whoa, fly!
Fly!
I do not wanna deal with that.
Okay.
It's fly time.
Ooh!
What if it goes inside corridors?
Okay.
Like, there's no reason to use my ult or like or like any of my abilities right now.
Phew!
Speed!
Uh oh.
Whoa.
I can do this.
Oh, shit!
Where the fuck did you come from?
Thank god he didn't land a direct.
Fucking right, nerd.
What are you gonna do?
You know what?
It's orbital time!
It's my useless ult time!
I think he's doing stuff, right?
I don't know.
I think so.
I can't tell.
I don't intimidate.
Oh.
I hear the Pharah.
Bro, that's not even Pharah, bro.
Ha ha ha ha!
Horrible.
Oh.
Oh, shit!
Where did you come from?
Where did the baby come from?
Hey, we did it.
I told you.
You mean...
God damn.
We just gave them the fucking meat.
There wasn't even an opponent.
I told you!
My point has been proven!
Overwatch has changed!
Ha ha ha ha!
I told you!
My point was proving!
Ha ha ha ha!
The meat was...
You guys were right!
No one has it.
David, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, we're calling it here though.
We're calling it here.
Ha ha ha ha!
We're gonna call it here for real.
That was...
Oh my god.
I told you guys.
I told you!
Nobody believed me!
Nobody believed me, but I was right!
I knew it!
But I'm so close to ranking.
You're right.
You're right guys.
I'm so close to ranking up though.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
But what...
But what if?
Chat, but what if...
Ha ha ha ha!
But what if I rank up to Masters right now?
Don't do it.
It's just...
It's just two more wins.
If I win two more, I'll be Master.
I'll be...
I'll be Diamond 1.
And then I'll be...
Okay, I'm gonna stop.
I'm gonna stop.
But that was fun.
I actually had a lot of fun there.
It was a lot.
It was all over the place.
The bot watchers are gonna be like Oh no, she played for five hours.
She must have... I wanna get off Mr. Toki's wild ride.
Thank you to Super Chat Cats.
Thank you.
Like...
Oh my god.
The first... The first half...
The first two hours... Rough.
Very rough.
But...
We... It got better.
It got better.
I told you guys.
It can get better.
There's always a light at the end of the tunnel.
But I had a lot of fun.
I told the Juno strat.
I perfected the Juno strat.
The moment I perfected the Juno strat, everything got so much easier.
Like, life just got easier.
I would...
Oh my god.
Anyway.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
Thank you to Super Chat.
Thank you.
Do you know the definition of insanity?
It's not insanity if we win, guys.
It's not insanity if we win, chat.
Anyway.
It was really fun.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching, too.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
Sorry.
For a moment, I forgot what the next line was.
It's not Overwatch's fault, though.
It's just silly me.
I'm just so stupid.
Right, Overwatch?
Yeah.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
I love Overwatch.